Lang chain is a framework for developing
applications powered by large language
models like gp4 in this course you will
learn Lang Chain by building six inin
projects with the open AI API Google
Gemini Pro and llama 2 you'll also learn
how to deploy projects to the hugging
face platform Chris neack developed this
course considering this here is an
amazing video of the entire Lang chain
crash course along with this we'll be
discussing six plus endtoend projects
llm projects using different different
llm models from open AI we'll be using
Lama 2 from meta we'll also be using
Google giny pro not only that we'll also
be using hugging face and we'll also be
seeing how we can deploy this in hugging
space uh platform itself which is
provided by hugging face itself right so
there will be somewhere around six plus
end to end projects we'll develop both
the front end back end I hope you enjoy
this entire Series this is a long video
so please make sure that you devote some
some amount of time every day and try to
practice as much more you can right so
in order to push this video to many
people out there guys I'll keep the like
Target to 2,000 please make sure that
you hit like share with all the friends
share your work in LinkedIn in different
platforms tag me over there I'll be very
happy to see what all things you
specifically developing so let's go
ahead and enjoy the series and I hope
you practice along with me all the
materials will be given in the
description of this particular video so
let's go ahead guys so finally finally
finally here is the langin series and
this is probably the first video where
I'm probably going to discuss a very
good one-hot video about Lang chain all
the important components that you
specifically need to know to build
projects now why I'm stressing on langin
is that because many people recently
some of my students and some of
experienced professional who switched
into data science Industry they are
getting work that are related to large
language models and they're specifically
using Lang chain and the community with
respect to langin is also increasing so
that is the reason I've created this
dedicated playlist and I'm going to
discuss a lot many things this video we
will understand all the important
competents of this Lang chain what you
specifically need to know with respect
to the Practical orientation and from
the next video onwards lot of end to
endend projects are probably going to
come up uh in this video also I'll
discuss about one Q&A project uh chatbot
in short you know we'll try to use
streamlet it's not like we only have to
use streamlet you can also use flask you
can use anything as you want right but
streamlet it provides you a good UI you
can also use gradio if you want right it
is up to you so what all things we are
specifically going to discuss first of
all we'll try to understand the agenda
and then we will try to uh do step by
step each and every line of code will be
done and as I said this is just like a
kind of L chain one shot video just to
give you an example that how we are
probably going to create our end to
endend application after we deploy that
in a specific cloud like hugging phas
right it provides your entire
environment to probably host your
application uh this is what we are going
to create this chatbot see if I probably
ask what is the capital of New oh sorry
of India then you'll be able to see that
I'm I'll be able to get the answer what
is the capital of Australia many people
get confused with the capital Australia
please do comment down in the comment
section what is the capital of Australia
and let's see whether it is right or not
so here you can see the capital of
Australia scan so we are going to create
this application at the end of the day
but before that we really need to
understand lot of important components
in Lang chain so let's go ahead and
let's start this particular session
before I go ahead please make sure that
you subscribe the channel press the Bell
notification icon and share with many
friend so that it will also be helpful
for them and it will also be helpful for
me so that you are able to provide this
open source content to everyone out
there many people require help and you
should be the medium to provide this
specific help by just sharing it right
so what is the agenda we'll understand
as I said this will be completely a
practical oriented video it'll be a long
video where I'll be talking more about
practical things how you can Implement
Lang chain how you can probably
implement various important
functionalities in Lang chain and use it
probably to build an endtoend
application so first of all we'll go
ahead and do the environment setup this
is commonly required you also require an
open AI key API key so this also I will
show you how it is done then we'll try
to build simple applications uh with the
help of llms three important things are
there llms prompt templates and output
parsel okay in llms you specifically
have llms and chat models chat models
are basically used in chat B to
understand the context reference and all
right I will also be discussing this
practical promt templates can play a
very important role and then coming to
the third one that is called as output
parser uh in short prompt template and
llms and output parser gives a very good
combination of output like it it'll give
you a good output the output like you
specifically want right so that is where
output Parcels will also be used before
to go ahead with what I will do is that
uh first of all just go to the open aai
uh website itself and get your API key
how you should get it just go to this
account and there you'll be able to see
view API key and create the new C secret
key right so once you create it give the
key name and then copy it and keep it
right I'm not going to share mine so
that is the reason why I'm showing you
this specific step now I will go to my
vs code all my coding will be done in
this VSS code itself here you can see it
is completely blank right I've just
opened a folder in the form of a project
now all you have to do start your
project over here now the first thing as
usual what we need to do we need to
create a new environment right so this
is the first step that you specifically
need to create with respect to an
environment so don't miss this specific
step it is important and probably
whatever projects that we are going to
discuss in the future we have to do the
specific step so I will write pip
install okay sorry cond create I'm
creating an environment so let me just
not open in Powers shelf instead I'll go
and open in command prompt okay so here
I will just right K create minus p v
EnV V
EnV
python equal to 3.9 so 3.9 is the
version that I'm going to specifically
use and also going to give- Y so that it
does not ask me for the permission
instead start creating the specific
environment the reason why I'm using
this environment understand one thing
that guys for every project that we
probably create we have to create a new
environment that actually helps us to
just understand or just use only those
libraries that are actually required for
this particular project okay so this is
the first step go ahead do it with me
you know uh and do it in vs code because
vs code is a good idea if you want to do
it in pycharm then also you can do it
but since you following this tutorial
I'm actually going to do it in vs code I
feel vs code is good I I've used both
okay I've used different different IDs
but I feel vs code is good okay so here
it is now here you can probably see my V
EnV environment uh the next thing we
will go ahead and activate this V EnV
environment so I will write cond
activate
cond activate V EnV Dash Okay so this is
my first step done I'm good with it now
the next thing what I will go to do is
that I will just go ahead and write my
requirement. thxt right because we need
to install the library since inside this
particular venv environment so I will go
ahead and write all the list of
libraries that I'm specifically going to
use now what are libraries I'm going to
use over here uh we will just write it
down so that uh the first library that
I'm going to use is Lang chain then open
Ai and I think I'll be using hugging
face also later on it is called as
hugging face Hub that I will show you as
we go ahead okay so these are the two
libraries that I'm going to specifically
use okay now the next thing what I will
do I will go ahead and write pip install
minus
r okay so let me just hide my face so
that you'll be able to see pip install
minus r requirement. txt so once this
installation will take place that
basically means my requirement. txt is
getting installed that basically means
all the libraries that I actually
require over here that is getting
installed and for this I require Lang
chain and open aai okay so once this
installation will will be taken place
like it will be done now one more
Library I'll be required is called as
IPI kernel because if I really want to
run any Jupiter notebook over here I
have to use that okay so let's wait and
let's see once the installation is
probably done and then we will continue
the video so guys the all the libraries
that were present in the requirement.
txt has been installed now the next step
that I'm probably going to do is also
install IPI kernel which will be
required to run my Jupiter notebook so I
will go ahead and write pip install iy
kernel Now understand one thing I'm not
writing this library in requirement. txt
because when we do the deployment in the
cloud IPI kernel will not be required
okay so that is the reason I'm
installing separately pip install IPI
kernel in the same VNV environment
because VNV environment also we are not
going to push it right so you can
probably see over here downloading this
this will happen and automatically the
download will happen itself right now
the next thing what I'm going to do I'm
just going to write Lang chain dot
ipynb okay py NB so this will basically
be my jupyter notebook that I will
specifically be using okay so right now
it is detecting kernel once this
installation will probably happen and
then we will also be able to see the
kernel okay so this is all the steps all
the basic steps that you probably
require from this you can start creating
end to endend project but at least you
require this uh along with this I'm also
going to add two more steps one is about
environment files EnV file okay so here
what I will do I will write Dov file
okay uh inside this EnV file the reason
why I'm uh writing this EnV file because
I need to probably use my open API key
and probably mention the open API key
over here so if I probably write it like
this and and whatever API key that I'm
probably getting from the website I can
upload it over here and using right uh
load environment function right we can
load this API key uh as a variable so
that we can actually call our API API
key over there so I will update this
later on as we go ahead okay so till
here everything is done this is my Lang
chin ipynb file I will go ahead and
detect the environment this is what
3.9.0 so here it is so let's see whether
it is working or not 1+ one it's working
right so this is perfectly all right so
everything over here is done with a
respect to this and I'm very much Happy
this is working uh which is really
really good okay so this is done now
what I am actually going to do over here
is that we need to import some of the
important libraries like open Ai and all
right so for this I will go ahead and
right from Lang
chain. llms
okay
import open AI see there there lot many
models like open llms and all first
we'll start with open AI understand one
thing guys the reason why I say this is
completely practical oriented because
you need to have the basic knowledge of
machine learning deep learning and all
but this specific libraries is used to
build application uh fine tune your
application with respect to models with
respect to your own data set most of the
things just with writing proper lines of
code will be implemented in an easier
way so you really need to focus on
things how things are basically done
okay now the next thing what I will do I
will write import OS and I will say OS
do Environ
environment okay and here I will give my
opencore API underscore key okay this is
how you should basically write it down
to import the API key now what I will do
I will keep this hidden from you so just
imagine I cannot show you the API key
because I will be using my own personal
API key itself so I will go ahead and
probably pause my video and update the
API key and I'll remove this specific
code okay that is what I'm actually
going to do so that none of you
basically sees that and it is important
you have to use your own API key so let
me quickly go ahead and do that and let
me come back so guys this is how you
have to probably import your API key
this will I've made some changes so if
you also copy it is not going to work I
made some internal changes in between
changes so uh you just need to write os.
environment open API key and this API
key that you have specifically got okay
so this is the initial step uh I have
also imported open AI so that I will be
able to call this particular uh open AI
itself now this is done this is good
everything is working Absol absolutely
fine now what I'm actually going to do
I'm going to create my llm model and go
ahead and write my open AI let's see
open AI open AI function is the called
or not let's see okay open AI from L
chin open Ai and inside this open AI
what I'm actually going to do I'm going
to basically call a variable which is
called as temperature and temperature
right now you can keep the value between
0 to 1 the more the value towards one
the more different kind of creative
answers you may get right if the value
is towards zero then what kind of output
you you are probably getting from the
llm model is going to be almost same
from the uh anytime you number anytime
you probably execute so here I'm just
going to keep it as 6 so this is
basically my open a llm model okay now
this is done my llm model is there so
here you can see did not find an open AI
key please add an environment variable
open AI key now this is the error that
you are specifically getting right so
why this particular error is probably
coming you should definitely understand
okay without
this understand that this kind of Errors
can come to you the reason why I will
not edit this particular error because I
really want you all to understand it is
saying did not find open API key now
what you can probably do with respect to
this okay there are two different things
that you can probably do either you can
take this API key save it in a constant
variable and try to use that particular
variable over here right so for that
also you can directly do that uh I have
also created this do EnV file what you
can do you can load this environment
variable and probably directly read it
over there right but let me just go
ahead with a simple way you know so you
will be able to understand with respect
to that also so here what I'm going to
do here I will go ahead and probably say
open API key and here I will going to
write OS do
environment okay and here I'm going to
Define my open API key okay now let's
see whether this will get executed or
not I will show you much more better
ways when we are probably executing our
end to end application so let me go
ahead uh open a key is not defined
because I use double equal to perfect
now you can see that it has got executed
perfectly now when I am actually
creating an end to end project I will
show you a better way the most efficient
way that we should specifically use when
we are building an end to end project
but right now I'll go to focus like this
now understand one thing is that with
respect to temperature variable right
the temperature that we specifically
used I will give a comment over here and
you can probably see over here right so
temperature value how creative we want
our model to be zero means temperature
it is it mean model is very safe it is
not taking any bets it will risk it
might generate wrong output may be
creative so more the value towards one
the more creative if the model becomes
right it is going to take more risk to
provide you some more better but again
with respect to risk again there may be
a problem you may get a wrong output
perfect this is the step simple step
that we have done at the end in this
video only I'm going to probably do
create an end to end project understand
this will be very important for everyone
because as we go ahead in the next
videos the project difficulty will keep
on increasing okay now this is done now
what I will do quickly I will go ahead
and write text let's say the text is
what is the capital of India okay so
here I will write print llm do predict
and here I'm going to basically write my
text so here you can see the capital of
India is New Delhi so here what I have
done is that this is my input and if we
use lm. predict I'm going to probably
get the text so if you like liking this
video till here guys as I'm teaching you
step by step I'm explaining you each and
everything please make sure that you
practice in a better way right if you
like it please make sure that you
subscribe the channel also okay so this
is done lm. predict and we are able to
probably get the output okay so
understand what what all things we did
we created an open AI model right but
here in the open AI right you should
also understand one important thing here
there is a parameter which is called as
model now what all model you can
probably bring it over here what all
model you can probably call so here I
will go to my documentation page okay
and uh if I probably click on the models
now here are the set of models that you
can probably use by default it is
calling this GPT 3.5 turbo it is the
most capable GPT 3.5 model and optimized
for chat at the 110th cost of a Dy 003
we'll be updated with our latest model
iteration 2 weeks after it is released
it's not like you only have to use this
you can use this you can use this you
can use this you can use this whatever
models you want you can probably use it
if you want to probably go with GPT 4
you can use this you can use this you
can use this but at the end of the day
gp4 is the most uh amazing thing it is
more capable than GPT 3.5 so this is
what models is by default over there it
is probably taking this specific model
which you can probably use it now as we
go ahead it is not like you can only
call this model itself in hugging face
you have open source models also right
from Google from different companies you
have that uh open source llm models you
can also call that and I will also show
you an example with respect to that okay
so till here I hope you have understood
it I think you should give a thumbs up
if you're able to understand till here
now let's go ahead and do one more thing
I will also show you with respect to
hugging face now okay now with respect
to hugging face what I will do I will
quickly go ahead head and write hugging
facehub right I will probably install
this library now let me go ahead and
open my
terminal okay so I will delete this and
quickly we will go ahead and write pip
install pip
install minr requirement.
txd done so this is getting executed and
then I will probably show you with
respect to hugging face also so hugging
face this is done okay the installation
is done so you have to use hugging face
Hub now in case of hugging face also
right you will specifically get
a you will also be getting a because at
the end of the day we'll also try to
deploy it over here if you go to
settings right and if you go to access
tokens here you can probably see I have
some kind of token right and with the
help of this particular token only you
will be able to call any models that are
available over here so in this models if
you probably go ahead and see there are
lot of llm models that are available
right so if you probably go over here
natural language token classification
question answer like uh let's say text
to text generation this is basically one
kind of llm model I will search for one
name okay so the name is
flan okay flan T5 base okay so this
specific model or T5 large this is a
text to text generation model right so
this is also an llm model if I want I
can use this also why I can use this
because this is an open source okay if
you want to probably see the answer
right text to text generat false or not
false or false is uh if I want to
compute it right it'll give me some
specific output okay false or false or
false is the verb the verb right
something like this it is getting an
output right so I can also use my I can
also create my chat models with the help
of this kind of models directly by using
this API right but how to do it let's go
ahead and see it okay so here what I
will do quickly I will first of all
import one more important thing again in
my environment
variable os. environment and here I'm
going to basically write in the case of
hugging P I have to use something called
as hugging oops I have to write in
capital letter hugging
face hubor API uncore to token okay so
here is my token okay hugging face Hub _
API _ token now with respect to this
particular token I have to write my own
token the token is basically given over
here as I have already shown you if I
probably click on show you'll also be
able to see it so I'm not going to do
the show part over here so what I will
do I will just pause the video upload it
execute it change the token and then
come back to you okay so let's go ahead
till then you can go ahead and create a
hugging face account also so guys now I
have set up my hugging face Hub API
token with this specific token again
I've made the changes so if you probably
use this again it will not work okay but
I have actually imported it now let's go
ahead and probably see how we can
probably call llm models with the help
of hugging face so again and again I'll
be using Lang chain Lang chin is just
like a wrapper it can call open llm
models it can call hugging face uh llm
models anything you can probably call
with it okay so that is the reason why
I'm saying it is powerful so I will
write from Lang chain okay
import hugging face Hub okay and then
here I'm going to probably Define
my let me just execute it and then
probably I will call it so here I will
go and write hugging face
Hub here first of all I need to give my
repo ID now repo ID is nothing but uh
whenever you search for any model this
will be your repo ID Okay Google slash
this okay so here I'm going to probably
go ahead and Define
it okay and this will basically be given
in a sentence
form okay so this is done now the next
thing that I will have is model quarks
okay and here I will go ahead and Define
my
temperature and then here I'll go ahead
and write max
length column 64 that basically means
I'm giving the maximum string length to
64 okay now let's see whether this will
execute or not I know it is going to
give us an error let's see so it is not
giving you an error it is probably
executing it perfectly it has probably
taken that particular key itself
inference API is working perfectly
everything is working so I will go ahead
and Define my variable so here I'm going
to basically write my l lmore hugging
face okay is equal to this one right so
this is done we have probably written
this specific thing over here and then I
will go ahead and write name or I will
see
output let's see the output and here I'm
going to basically write llm do hugging
face do predict and let's say I'll say
can you tell me the capital of of Russia
okay so let's see whether we will be
able to get the output or not so here
I'm going to write print output and
let's see whether we are so here you can
see the output is a simple word right
the capital of Russia is Moscow right
but here the previous output that we saw
with respect to the llm models here it
shows that capital of India is New Delhi
it is giving you entire sentence and
probably here it is just giving you a
word and this is what the difference is
with respect to an open source uh model
itself and models like GPD 3.5 or 4
right so here uh you can probably see
this okay and I will also execute one
more thing over here let's see uh can
you write a
poem can you write a
poem about
AI let's say I give this what kind of
poem it
gives okay it probably taking time to
probably give the I love the way I look
at the world I love the way I
feel the way I think I feel I love the
way I love see what kind of output
you're specifically getting right now if
I probably give the same output and
probably write
llm okay dot
predict llm dot predict and if I
probably give the same sentence let's
see what is the output now you will be
able to understand why we are
specifically using
this let's
see it should give you a better output I
think I love the way I look at the world
oh so mysterious was so curious It's
technology so advanced IT Evolution so
enhance it's a tool that can assist um
in making life much less hectic a force
that can be used for good or a cause
that's misunderstood it can make
decisions so Swift and learn from the
sto Swift tool that can be better see so
how what an amazing poem it has
basically written and by this you'll be
able to understand the differences why
I'm specifically using this open AI
model and with respect to hugging face
yes there are also some models which you
can probably take paid one in hugging
face that will give you better output
but this is what happens with respect to
open source uh models I think we should
uh we have lot of Open Source models
that are probably coming up Mr 7B and
all that also we'll be seeing in this
playlist as we go ahead but as I said
this is just a basic thing to probably
understand we will be focusing on
understanding these things right so here
uh till here I hope we have discussed so
many things how to probably call open AI
models with respect to open AI uh
Library API itself and then hugging face
API also llm models right and using Lang
chain so here are what all things we
have done now the next thing that we are
probably going to discuss is about
prompt templates prompt template is
super amazing uh it will be very very
handy when we are talking about about
things with respect to prom template and
all so that also we are going to discuss
as we go ahead so guys now let's go
ahead and discuss about prompt templates
which is again a very handy component in
the Lang chain even in open AI with the
help of prompt templates you will be
able to get efficient answers from the
llm models itself right I'm not talking
about prompt engineering that can get
you three CR package okay I'm just
talking about simple prompt templates
and how prompt templates can be probably
used okay now now let's go ahead and
first of all import from Lang
chain from Lang chain. prompts import
prompt template okay uh what we are
going to do is that whenever we call a
specific llm model you know the llm
model should know what kind of input it
is probably expecting from the client or
from the end user and what kind of
output it should probably give it okay
so what we do if you want to really
Define how our input should be and how
our output should be we can specifically
use prompt template because understand
if we directly use GPD 3.5 it can be
used for various purposes right but here
I want to restrict all those things
within something right so with respect
to the input and the output so here I'm
going to probably Define my promt
template so let me go ahead and Define
my promt template now with respect to
the promt template here first thing that
we need to Define is our input variables
so here I will go ahead and write write
my input
variables okay now in input variables we
need to first of all say that what input
we are specifically giving there will be
a fixed template in that template I
really need to give my input okay so
let's say here I Define my input and
here I'm just using one input let's say
the capital or the country I'm just
going to write it as country okay so
this is my first parameter that I'm
going to probably give in my template
itself and this I will also store it in
my variable which is called as promt
template
okay great now here I'm given country as
my input variable okay here I will
Define my
template now inside this template what
I'm going to say is that tell me the
capital
of
this whatever template that I'm
specifically giving that is country
so this is just like my variable
whenever I give the input to this
variable it is going to replace it over
here right so what will happen by this
is that the open AI will be able to
understand okay this is the question
that is asked but this value is dynamic
that I'm probably giving it during the
run time something like that okay now
here if I want to execute this again I
can also write
prompt uncore template
okay prompt undor
template uh dot format right so there is
a function called as do format and here
now instead of how should I give my
input so here I will say
country is equal to right whatever the
variable name is country is equal to
let's say
India okay now here you can see that my
entire prompt is generated in this way
saying that tell me the capital of India
okay so here you can probably see tell
me the capital of India right now if I
want to probably predict I will write
llm do predict okay and here I will just
say prompt template is equal to whatever
my prompt template is defined so here
I'm getting an error predict missing one
required positional argument text now
inside this I've given this prom
template but it is expecting one text
right what is that particular text that
that is particular this particular value
right so here what I will do I will go
ahead and Define my second variable text
and here I will write it as India let's
see whether it will get executed still
it is giving me an error so guys now you
can see when I'm using this llm do
predict and I've given my prompt
template I've given my text also that
was the error that was coming but still
it is giving me an error saying that the
prompt is expected to be a string
instead found class list this this if
you want to run the llm multiple prompts
use gener instead okay something like
this I will show you a way because that
is the reason the reason I'm keeping
this error over here there is a simple
way of understanding things right
because this is not the right way to
call promt template along with the
inputs itself so what I'm going to do
quickly I will go ahead and import one
important thing that is called as chains
so I will say from Lang chain dot
chains import llm chain understand one
thing guys chain basically means combine
multiple things and then probably
execute I have my llm model I have my
prompt I know I have to give my input
based on that input I need to probably
get the output so instead of executing
directly by using llm do predict I'm
going to use llm chain and inside that
I'm going to give my llm model I'm going
to give the prom template and I'm also
going to give the input so this is what
we are specifically going to do now this
will get gots executed from Lang chain.
chain import llm chain now I'm going to
create my chain let's say the chain is
equal to
llm
chain and here I'm going to basically
write llm is equal to llm okay whatever
is my llm model and my prompt is equal
to my prompt template okay now this is
there this is my chain not chain what it
is doing it is combining the llm model
it knows what is the prompt template
right I'm going to use both of them and
now in order to run it so I will write
chain. run and here I will say India
let's say I'm going to probably say
India and I know what is the output it
is going to get tell me the capital of
India so if I write chain. run it is
definitely going to give me the output
the capital of India is New Delhi this
is perfect right so I can also probably
print it right see guys I'm not going to
delete any of the errors I want you all
to see the errors and then try to
understand that is the best way of
learning things okay other than this
there is no other way right you need to
find a way to learn things you don't
worry about any errors that are probably
coming up you just worry about okay fine
you have got that error how you can
probably fix that what is the alternate
way of probably fixing it right so you
can probably use all these techniques as
we go ahead right so this is with
respect to prompt template and here I'm
going to also talk about and llm chain
right so these are some important things
because all these things we will
probably be using in creating our end to
end application now let's go ahead and
probably discuss some more examples with
respect to llm so guys now we are
understanding one more important topic
which is called as combining multiple
chains using simple sequential chain
till here we have understood about llm
chain LM chain was able to combine an
llm model along with the prompt template
through which we can also give our input
and get our specific output now if I
have multiple chain let's say if I'm
giving one input I want to use those
input in both the chain or three chains
four chains how can I specifically do it
and for that I'm going to probably use
Simple sequential chain okay so let us
go ahead and let us probably see how
this can probably be done so first of
all I will probably say Capital template
prompt Capital prompt okay so first like
what is the capital of this specific
country right so this will basically be
my prompt so here I'm going to use my
prompt template and here I'm going to
basically use input variables is equal
to and here I'm going to basically say
country let's go to the
next input the next input will basically
be
template and here I will say I want uh
please tell me
the capital of of the whatever input I'm
specifically giving away as country so
this becomes my first template right and
what I will do I will create a chain the
chain name will be Capital chain okay
and here I'm going to probably use my
llm chain and my llm model will be llm
okay and then I will also be using
my prom template is equal to as capital
template capital
template okay so this is done let's see
Capital prompt what is capital prompt oh
sorry Capital
prompt Capital prompt is not defined
why uh please tell me the capital of
this uh
template oh double equal to Let's it no
worries uh two validation error for LM
chain so first I've used an LM chain
where prompt template is equal to this
uh where it is capital prompt so guys
after just checking the documentation
this should be prompt itself okay
because in llm chain we have used prompt
and here is capital template here also
I'm going to probably use Capital
tempate now if I execute this this works
absolutely fine uh one thing you can
probably see over here that I've given
my template name and then I've also
given the capital chain right so if I
want to probably execute it I can just
give my chain. run and that particular
parameter okay but now what I want is
that I also want to create one more
prompt template I want to give the same
input to that chain also so here uh
let's say I will write famous _ template
and I will just say promp template and
here again my input variable what is my
input variable so my input variable will
be whatever specific things that I'm
trying to give right let's say please
tell me the capital of uh India if I say
right the capital whatever Capital I'm
going to get that variable only I'm
going to pass it over here so my input
variable will basically be my capital
okay and this will be my second one and
here I'm going to probably sayest
template and I'm going to probably ask a
question suggest
me some amazing
things amazing some amazing
places places to visit
in that specific capital okay so this is
what I'm probably telling right please
tell me the capital of the country so I
will have that capital information that
will be my input variable to from this
particular template uh in that specific
chain okay so I will get two answers
first of all I'll get the capital of
that particular country and then what
are the some amazing places to visit in
that specific Capital place okay so
these are all the information that I
have put up okay so I hope this also
works fine now now what I'm going to
create I'm going to create an another
chain which will be for this particular
famous chain right so here I'll write
famous chain okay is equal to and I'm
going to probably use my llm chain oh
llm chain and here I'm going to give my
llm models but the second one that is my
prompt is equal to uh whatever template
that I'm going probably going to give
the famous template okay so this is what
I'm probably going to do uh and I've
probably given this prompt also over
there and this will basically be my
chain so once I probably execute it both
the chains are ready now I need to give
one input it should go to one chain get
the output from that particular chain
and pass that output to the next chain
okay so this is what I specifically want
to do how can I do it so again from Lang
chain do chains I'm going to import
simple sequential chain I know guys uh
here you may be thinking why I have to
use this see you're passing one input to
the get the other output from the one
chain and pass that particular output to
the other chain to get the just output
itself right so this is quite amazing
when you see an end to end application
there you'll be able to understand these
are some of the important components you
should definitely know and try to
understand okay so here finally what I'm
going to do is that I'm going to
probably create my chain is equal to and
this will be my final chain and here I
will probably say I'll import this okay
so I get that so chain is equal to
simple sequential
chain capital letter simple sequential
chain and inside the simple sequen chain
I just have to name all my chains what
all chains are specifically there in the
form of list so the first chain uh that
I have over here is nothing but Capital
chain the second chain that I have is
something called as famous chain okay so
both the chains are ready now in order
to run it all I have to do will write
chain. run and here I'll specifically
give India
okay done let's see what kind of output
I will probably
get so it is running it is a bustling
Metro Police and a great place to visit
for historical site cultural this this
this red Fort see most popular city the
iconic monal is a multivisit who fought
in World War one the 16th century mugal
era Tom in UNESCO world heritage site
everything it is probably giving it
right so it did not give us the first
answer with respect to the chain because
it only provides the last input
information okay uh if you want to
probably display the entire chain I will
show you a way how to do that for that
we have to use buffer memory uh there
will be something called as buffer
memory but one amazing thing I gave one
input I got the output and then probably
I pass that particular output to my next
chain and I able to to get one amazing
out answer over here so definitely try
it out from your side by using different
different examples also now what I'm
going to do is that I'm going to
probably discuss one very important
component about chat model open AI so
that is also super important uh that is
something related to chat models
whenever you probably want to create a
chart models you can have to use that
okay so let's have a look onto that so
guys one more additional thing that
let's say I want to probably see the
entire chain so here we will
specifically use something called as
sequential chain and let me just show
you one example of that also uh it is
not much to do with respect to that but
you should definitely know this
important video as said again I don't
want to probably take more time with
respect to this but it is good to know
this okay sometime when you are
developing things and that you'll
probably be understanding once I start
end to end project right today one end
to end project will be done okay don't
worry about this uh in this particular
video it will be done uh but definitely
I want to show this example also as we
go ahead now now uh let's quickly go
ahead and do the same thing I will copy
this
entirely okay I will paste it over here
okay now along with llm promt template I
will give my output key also so where I
specifically want my output key so the
output key will be nothing but it will
be something called as capital okay so
this is my Capital chain with this
specific output okay so here I have
created this now let's go ahead and
probably create the next template
uh that is this famous template
okay so here also you can probably see
the famous template uh suggest me some
names of the capital and here I've
probably created my template name uh and
my chain is over here right so this will
basically be my chain okay so the same
name whatever output Keys over here I've
given this as my input key and here uh I
can also derive one output key like this
output
key places something like this okay so
done this is done see two simple
templates that I actually created uh s
me some amazing places to visit in this
particular Capital uh the capital is
probably given from here so now the
chain will probably be able to
understand each and everything as we go
ahead you know where the output is and
all right so here now what I'm going to
do I'm going to probably import from
Lang
chain do chain
chains
import sequential chain okay and then
finally you can see I'll write chain is
equal
to
simple okay I will let me just execute
this because it is not giving me any
suggestion so I will write chain is
equal to
sequential chain and now I'll Give All
My Chains name so the first chain name
is um to Capital chain
D famous chain
dang okay and uh after
this you will basically be able to
understand the input
variables now the input variables that
we specifically
have input variables is nothing but
whatever is my variable name what is the
variable name in this case it is nothing
but country
okay and then my output variable I'll
also create my output uncore
variables so these are the two
parameters see guys this this parameters
is nothing but whatever parameters I'm
specifically giving one is the
capital and one is the
places done so this is my entire chain
now if I want to run any chain what I
will do I'll basically write something
like this and give what is my country
name right so it should be given in the
form of key value pairs so here is my
country
colon India right something like this
now if I execute it I will now be able
to see my entire chain right it'll take
some time so what I have done over here
I have in every llm chain that I'm
probably creating I'm creating an output
key uh two chains so two output key and
here you can see chain country India
country was India Capital the capital of
India is New Delhi here are some amazing
places to visit in New Delhi and all the
information I have probably over here
now let's go ahead and discuss chat
models uh specifically in Lang chain and
we also going to use one Library which
is called as chat openi uh this is also
very good if you want to probably create
a conversational uh chat bot itself so
in chat models with chat open AI first
of all what we will do is that we will
go ahead and import Lang chain uh do
chatore
models and I'm going to probably import
chat open aai so we will quickly go
ahead and import it now after I
specifically import this in chat open AI
there are three schemas that you really
need to understand okay whenever a
conversation basically happens if a
human is probably giving some kind of
input and expecting some response that
basically becomes a human message right
if by default when the when your chat
bot is probably opening a default
message will probably come right and
that is something related to domain like
what that specific chatbot does right so
it can probably come up with a new
schema which is called as system message
and then there is also one more message
which is called as AI message which is
again a schema which probably gives the
output right whatever the chatbot is
giving an output uh the AI whatever
models is specifically giving the output
that is nothing but that is related to
the schema that is called as AI message
okay now from this here we what we are
going to do we are going to import from
langin do
schema I'm going to
import human message
system message right as I said system
message is also required and AI message
here everything you'll be able to get
this as an example because uh probably
in the upcoming videos we'll create
conversational U chat bot right at that
point of time we'll be seeing all these
things what we'll be using and how we
will be using okay so here quickly we'll
import this now uh obviously my llm
model is there right by uh and while
creating before the llm models how did
we use it we basically use something
called as uh open a right we used open
AI now in this case I will probably copy
the same thing
okay and I will just past it over here
and write chat llm okay and instead of
writing open AI I'll use chat open AI
right so this is what I'm specifically
going to use chat open AI with some
temperature in this and here I'm also
going to give one model so let me go
ahead and write my model name uh the
model name that we are going to
basically write from here is GPT
3.5 Das turbo right I showed you like
what models we can specifically use so
this is my chat llm model so here if I
probably go ahead and write my chat llm
so here you'll be able to see that it is
a chat open AI uh and with all the
information with so temperature what is
the uh this and all open AI key I cannot
show you so it shows you open AI key
also over here so going to remove this
okay so that you don't find the opening
I key now let's use this three schema
and then probably see how my output will
look like let's say first of all I'll
create the schema in the form of list
okay first of all the system message
right let's say system message I will go
ahead and initialize and I'll write a
content content one variable is there I
say you are an you are a
comedian
AI assistant okay so this is the this is
what I'm telling the chatbot to behave
like right it is basically acting like a
comedian AI assistant okay then in the
next one I will say human message and
here again I will go ahead and write the
content and I will say
please and this is
what I will probably write as a human
this is what the input that I am
probably giving right
so I'll say
please make a
comedy about
or please provide some punch lines some
comedy punch
lines punch
lines on okay AI
okay so here you can probably see these
are my two things these are the two
information that I'm going to give to my
chat llm models right and then let's see
what is the output okay with respect to
that now in order to give this input to
my chat llm so I will write chat llm and
here only I will open my
brackets so it has two information first
by default it knows the system is a
comedian AI assistant and here as a
human input what we are saying is that
we are saying please provide some comedy
punch lines on AI okay so if I execute
this you will be able to see I will be
able to get an output
now this is how we are going to design
later on in the end to endend project we
are not going to give this as a
hardcoded it'll be quite Dynamic so here
you can see AI message see this is the
output if I'm getting the output that
basically becomes an AI message so this
schema that we are able to see from the
output of this particular chatbot the
system message is basically telling that
okay beforehand you have to act
something like that we instructing the
chatbot to probably act in that way
right the human message is basically our
input and AI message is what is the
output so AI may be smart but it can
tell me if your output makes look like a
potato AI is a virtual therapist except
it never judges you for eating an entire
Pizza by yourself something like this so
this is what comedy messages you can
probably see right and I think this is
quite amazing and you can probably set
this up any number of time right you can
probably say you can add this AI message
over here and you can still build more
conversational AI right so as AI also
give the message you can probably store
it inside this s let's say if I probably
consider a list and I append this
particular list with all this
information it can act as a chat model
as our as we go ahead right now guys we
are also going to discuss about one
topic and after this we are going to
implement our project okay so over here
we going to discuss about prom template
plus llm plus output parcel now first of
all we'll try to understand what exactly
is output parcel now in order to make
you understand about output plaster and
how we can probably implement it I will
use Lang chain again for this um as said
guys langin is a powerful Library it has
everything as a wrapper right so I will
say from Lang chain okay from Lang
chain.
chatore models first of all I'm going to
import chat open AI okay chat open AI I
see there so many things Chad vertex AI
chap open AI very powerful very powerful
and the way it is getting developed
right quite amazing right so from Lang
chain dot prompts I'm also going to use
some prompts and like how we have a
prompt template when we use open AI
right similarly in chat open AI we use
uh prompts which is basically called as
chat promate chat prompt template okay
so I'm going to basically import
chat prompt value no
template chat prompt template so I'm
also going to import this along with
this as I said output parser right
output parser is that if I want to
modify any output of an llm model
beforehand right so I can specifically
use output parsers so for Lang chain I
will also import this from Lang chain do
schema import base output parel right so
these are the three things I'm
specifically importing and here I'll
basically go ahead and write class let's
say I am defining one output parser and
I'll Define this in the form of class
it'll inherit the base output class so
let's say uh I will say comma separated
output okay that basically means it is
basically called as a comma separated
output this is the class that I'm going
to Define and uh
even even in the documentation it is
given in an amazing way okay so comma
separated output and this will basically
be inheriting the base output parcel
okay now inheriting when I probably
inherit right that basically means we
are inheriting this base output par and
we can call this along with an llm
models here I will Define a parse method
and inside this par I will take self as
one keyword and whatever text the output
that we have specifically getting which
will be in the form of string format all
we'll do we'll just write return text.
strip
dot dot split right and this will be a
comma separated
split understand one thing now this is
what is the class that I've defined and
this is just like an output parser by
default the output parser is what you
can probably see whenever I'm
specifically using the chat models I'm
I'm getting some kind of output right AI
may be smart something it is giving in
the form of sentence and it is adding a
new line at the end but what I'm saying
is that whatever output I'm getting I
will take that output and divide all the
words in comma separated okay something
like that so for this again I will
Define my template I will
say you are
a
helpful assistant okay so this is my
first message that is probably going as
a template right so this becomes a
system template the schema that we
probably discussed right I will also
give some
information um let's
say when the user gives any
input okay you
should generate five words okay in a
comma separated list so this is what is
my entire message okay the template I'm
saying that whenever the user give any
input you have to probably generate five
words which should be comma separated
okay so this is what I have specifically
done okay now what will be the input
what will be the text Will Define all
those things okay and here I will say
this will be my human template so what
is the word that I'm going to probably
give over here uh that will specifically
defined over here right so here I will
say Okay test uh you should generate
five
words synonym let's say synonym I'll
just go ahead and write synonyms okay
synonyms in comma separated so here will
basically be my text whatever text I'm
specifically given now I will go ahead
and create my chat prompt now again from
this chat prompt what I have to use I've
already used chat prompt Pro template
okay and inside this I will say do from
message let's see that chat prompt
template
from from underscore messages okay now
inside this from underscore messages I
have to give two information okay
whatever is the template right so first
template is nothing but the system one
so system information that I really want
to give uh that system one is nothing
but this normal template that I've
defined and the second one will
basically be my human template right
whatever human message that I'm actually
giving right and this will basically be
defined as human uncore temp temp
plates template right so once I execute
it here you'll be able to see this is my
chat prompt okay now in order to execute
this obviously I have to use chain right
because I have a prom template over here
I have a human text I have this specific
template also so how do I probably
combine all these things that is what
I'm actually going to show you over here
so quickly first of all I will use this
chat llm okay chat llm now see this is
quite amazing and this is the best way
of running chains so I will say chain is
equal to whatever is my chat prompt so
this is my chat
prompt to this chat prompt I will give
my
API whatever API I'll write over here
control V so I have to just give a or
sign kind of thing right so this is
getting chained up this symbol basically
says that it is getting chained up and
remember the order also okay or you can
also initialize chat open AI over here
now along with this I will also give my
output parser the output parser will be
the last one right so this will
basically be my output parser comma
separated output okay now see I've given
each and everything over here one by one
list by list right so here it is so once
I probably execute it it will get
executed so here what it is saying I'm
giving this chat prompt the chat llm
model is there and the output should be
comma separated output which is getting
derived from this particular class okay
now here finally what I will do I will
write chain do
invoke and inside this I will again
whenever I use chain I have to probably
give it in a key value pair right colon
something whatever the value is now in
this case I will say the word is um
intelligent let's say now I have to
probably give in the form of text right
so that is what I really have to give it
right so this text is equal to in now
let's see what is the output uh it is
coming as okay there is some syntax
issue that I have probably made because
I have to close my dictionary over
here now if I write chain. inor you can
see that five words smart clever
brilliant
shop aute I don't know this specific
word but here you'll be able to see
whatever output that I'm probably
getting right so if I probably remove
this let's see okay this is how the
output will look like okay AI message
content this this this right but just by
adding this output parsel you can see
what an amazing message you're able to
get and you're getting able to get the
right thing that you specifically want
this is what powerful a prompt template
is all about right now this is done
right and this is more than sufficient
to know because more new things about
PDF how to read PDF how to what is text
iding and all we will discuss as we go
ahead
but now let us go ahead and try to
create a simple chatbot okay simple
chatbot I'll create an app.py and by
using the simple chat bot we'll try to
understand how things actually work and
what all things we can basically do okay
again here I'm going to probably use
streamlet and I'll be writing the code
line by line so let's go ahead and have
a
look so guys finally now we are going to
develop our Q&A chatbot uh with all the
concepts that we have probably learned
I'm just not going to use all the
concepts right now in this specific
video itself because we should have
probably uh 10 to 12 projects that are
going to come up in the future in this
series of playlist so there we are going
to discuss about more projects as we go
ahead right but now in this video I'm
going to probably create a simple Q&A
chatbot just with the help of open aai
Lang chin and obviously use openi apis
and llm models specifically to do that
that here I'm also going to use
streamlet okay so let's go ahead and
let's see initially what all settings I
need to do see this was Lang chain. iynb
because I will be giving you this entire
file uh again in the reference with
respect to GitHub also so uh first of
all in the requirement. txt I will be
importing one more library because I
need to install this Library this is the
important Library itself which is
python. EnV right so python d.v actually
helps us to create or upload all our uh
environment variables that we have
created with respect to our application
so here this is the library that I have
to do it and just go ahead and install
the requirement. txt I've already done
that uh and this will be a specific task
to you now we are starting over here so
from lin. llms I have imported open aai
then from EnV load load. EnV so as soon
as I probably call this it will take all
the environment variables from EMV file
so here I've already created the
environment variable I'm not going to
show you again the environment variable
because in short the environment
variable will be something like this see
I I I may have written like something
like this open AP opencore API _ key is
equal to this particular environment
variable right so this is basically my
open uh API key itself right so I'm
going to probably use this uh in my
application so here uh these are the
basic steps that we will probably go
ahead with now along with this what I'm
actually going to do I'm also going to
to import one more Library which is
called as streamlet because we are going
to use streamlet itself so let me go
ahead and open my terminal and quickly
let's go ahead and write pip
install minus
r minus r requirement. txt and then the
installation will start taking place and
the streamlet uh Library will also get
installed Streamlight we are
specifically using for a front-end
application uh see it's it's not light
only you have to use streamlet it'll be
very much easy for me to probably create
it and do the deployment because I'm
also going to show you the deployment in
the hugging face uh space itself right
what is exactly hugging space uh space I
will also discuss about all those things
so quickly uh let's do this uh it'll
probably take some time and then I will
go to my app. Pui uh let me do one thing
quickly uh let me go ahead and import
streamlet also so I'll import
streamlet as St okay so this will
basically my streamlet itself okay so
it'll probably take some time to
download it let's see how much time it
is going to take but again it depends on
your internet speed and how fast your
system is right my system is really
really fast till it is taking
time so for you it may probably take
more time okay so let this installation
take place till then I will go ahead and
start creating our application now I
will first of all create a
function to load open AI model and get
response okay get
response so I will call this function
something like definition um getor open
AI response okay something like this and
here I'm probably going to give since it
is a Q&A chatbot so here I will have my
question as my parameter which will be
of a string type okay it can be a string
type it can also be a numerical type so
I will just keep it like this okay so
this is done and here you can also see
the installation is done so I will just
close this now here as soon as I
probably call this function what I
really need to do I need to call my llm
model so llm model I will say open AI
okay open Ai and here I will go ahead
and Define my
model uh have I imported open AI yes I
have imported model uh uh open itself so
I will go ahead and write model uncore
name is equal to and I will will Define
my model I'll be using text Davin
C uh this is one of the model that we
have you can probably refer it so text
Davy
003 and here I'm also going to Define my
temperature temperature is equal to
let's
say5 Okay uh along with this uh I'll
just go ahead and copy one more thing I
will just set up my open API key also so
I will set it up like by using this OS
environment so here will be my first
parameter okay so all this is done uh I
think I need to also import OS okay so
this is done in short what I'm doing is
that I'm initializing my llm model OKAY
in this code now the next thing is that
I need to probably get my response so
response will be nothing but llm
directly how do I give a question over
here I can probably give the question
over here okay see I'm just creating a
basic one
then whatever things you really want to
do from here you can probably do it try
to create a own prom template try to use
chain if you want try to do multiple
things but just to start with I'm going
to use a simple application where it is
just taking an input and giving some
kind of output it has no AI message set
it has no human system message set no
system message set also we have not
given any prompt template also over here
this just to give you an idea how things
starts okay so now we will
initialize in initialize our streamlet
app okay now with respect to streamlet I
will write STD do
set underscore
page underscore config so this is one of
the function in streamlet which will
actually help you to set the page title
so I will just go ahead and write title
is equal to I will say q& a demo okay Q
a demo and this is done with respect to
my uh and here I will set my another
header the header will be something like
Lang
chain application something like this
okay so I've given my header also with
respect to this okay now I need to find
out a way to get a user input okay uh if
I get a user input then I should be able
to submit the button and I should be
able to get the text itself so first of
all I will go ahead and create my submit
button I will say St do
button and here I will go ahead and
write generate generate or ask the
question something like this
okay
if ask button is
clicked right if it is clicked that
basically means if I write if submit
okay if it is clicked this usually
becomes true okay so if this is true it
is probably going inside this particular
function and here you'll be able to see
s I'll just put a header and uh I'll say
the
response is okay and then I will
probably write St dot right with respect
to the response okay so this is what I
am probably doing it okay I'm getting
the response over here and with respect
to this specific response I will
probably this response is probably
coming from here but still whatever is
the input that input we are not able to
capture it yet right because if we
capture those input then only we'll be
able to send that particular input
somewhere right and for that also I may
have to probably create another function
so let's go ahead and handle the input
part
now so guys now what I am actually going
to do over here is that first of all
we'll go ahead and and capture our input
text so let me go ahead and write over
here input is equal to St do textor
input because I'm going to use a text
field over there and here I will
probably be waiting for the response
itself right so sorry from the request
right so so here I will write input
colon okay and I'll keep a space over
here and I will just write key is equal
to key is equal to input something like
this so this will basically be my input
itself okay now once I've done this okay
once I've have done this I'm going to
take this particular input and now call
I hope you should know what we should
call we should basically call this
function right so this here I'm going to
probably write uh not here itself uh so
let me just write it over here and this
input I'm actually giving it over
here okay so this will basically be my
input over here uh whatever input I'm
probably getting it it'll just go ahead
with respect to this particular question
and I will probably get the response
here I will just go ahead and write
return
response okay and then I will store this
particular variable inside my response
okay done see the way I probably got the
input over here I sent this input to my
get open AI response my open AI model
has got probably loaded and then it is
basically calling with respect to this
llm you can either call predict message
or predict functionality also uh you can
also use chain you can use multiple
things you can assign promt template in
this particular function and all right
and then finally you have S do Button as
the button and if submit this is there
okay now quickly let's go ahead and
probably run it
okay uh let me see whether if I directly
call python app. Pui it will give us a
error why because it is a stream L
library right if it was flask I would
have probably said okay it would have
work ke now it says key error open API
key okay so os. environment open API key
load.
EnV so guys one mistake that I have
specifically done whenever I really want
to call all the environment variables
from EnV with the help of load uh this
the specific library that is called as
this this functionality which is load.
EnV at that point of time I'll be using
get EnV function and here I will just
remove all the things brackets and
probably call this function now I hope
so it should work and I think we should
not get any problem so Streamlight run
app.py and here we have our entire
application quickly it's running let's
see um this is getting
loaded and here we have right now
probably I'll ask the question what is
the capital of India right so I'll just
ask the question over here the response
is the capital of India is New
Delhi um let's see what is generative AI
right so I'll ask the question you'll be
able to see that generative AI is a type
of artificial intelligence that focuses
on creating new data from existing data
this this this is there still I'm I'm
getting some kind of weird responses
over here so that is the reason we'll
also be using output parsers we'll make
sure that we'll use conversation buffer
memory we'll also Implement schemas like
human message system uh human human
system AI system um system messages all
those things were there right all the
schemas that part we probably discussed
but this is a simple application that we
are probably going to discuss with
respect to this it is going to be quite
amazing and uh you know this is just a
basic Q&A chat bot uh wherein whatever
questions you specifically ask like what
is the
please right write a
poem
on on please write a romantic poem I'll
just give it as romantic
poem on generative AI something like
this because many people are now using
this ask the
question so here you can see gener way I
knew love in my life your data driven
hurt is perfect fit your algorithm so
precise your knowledge is so wise so
everything is over here now what I'm
actually going to do is that I will go
and show you the deployment part
everything is working fine I will first
of all login into the hugging face go to
the spaces and create a new space
because I'm going to probably do the
deployment over here let's say I will
say Lang chain Q&A chatbot okay I don't
have to use license this will be a
streamlet now in space Hardware like you
have paid Hardwares also but I'm
probably going to use a simple one CPU
Basics 2v CPU 16GB and I will create
this as public so that you can also
refer it um let's see okay I will just
remove this spaces please match okay
this underscore is not there QA a
chatbot I will go ahead and create the
space now after creating the space uh
there's couple of things that I'm
probably going to do over here is that
uh this is where this is just like a
GitHub repository you know you if you
probably go to the files you'll be able
to see it now here I'm probably going to
upload the file that I have okay uh but
before that what I'm actually going to
do I'll go to my settings okay and if I
go down right so there will be something
called as secret keys because this
secret key I have to put it with respect
to open AI so here no secrets are there
so I will go and clear or click on uh
new secret and you know that with
respect to the new secret what I have to
probably use I have to use open API key
I will put it over here okay and now
oops just a second open API key let me
open
this and I will put it over here okay
and what I'm going to do I'm also going
to upload the value okay so I'll not
show you the value uh let me update this
and let me come back and quickly and
show you the next steps that we are
probably going to
do after adding the open AI API key uh
you can see it over here in the secrets
you'll be able to see this specific key
now what I will do after updating that I
will go to my app now again my entire
application will start getting buil up
now here you can see as soon as I add
the open AI API you'll be able to see my
application will start running now here
I can probably ask question what is the
capital of India okay and uh you can see
that I will be able to get the response
now clearly you'll be able to see uh
I've been able to do the deployment in
hugging pH spaces uh it was very much
simple you can see the files over here
itself on the app.py requirement. txt I
had commented out all the codes with
respect to EnV and all because soon as
we add the secret variable as soon as
this open a model is called it is going
to take the open a API key from there
and it is going to use it over here so
yes this was with respect to the
deployment and quickly we were able to
also create a simple Q&A chatbot along
with deployment so guys in this video
we're going to create one Amazing llm
Project which is nothing but PDF query
with langen and cassendra DB uh
cassendra DB will be probably creating
in a platform which is called as data
Stacks so if you have probably heard
about this particular platform which is
called as data Stacks which will
actually help you to create cassendra DB
in the cloud itself and why this
platform is quite amazing because from
this you will be able to perform Vector
search and whenever we talk about this
kind of documents or if you want to
really create an Q&A applications from
huge PDFs itself Vector search is the
thing that you really need to implement
now before I go ahead let's first of all
understand the entire architecture we
will be solving this entirely step by
step what are the steps specifically
that will be taken to probably complete
this specific project that we really
need to understand so let's begin with
the architecture initially let's say you
have a specific PDF this PDF can be of
any size and any number of pages first
of all we will read the documents and
understand here we are going to use
langin as I said because langin has some
amazing amazing functionalities which
will actually help you to perform all
the necessary tasks to create this
specific application now first we will
go ahead and read the documents that is
specifically the PDF and the first step
usually when we whenever we work with
this kind of data set is with respect to
some kind of transformation we really
need to do so after reading this
documents we will convert this into
various test chunks that basically means
we'll split the data set into some kind
of packets right so this text Chunk will
be of some specific size based on the
tokens that we are probably going to use
so over here you can see some example
reading the document and then we have
divided this into some chunks then we
will convert all this chunk into text
embeddings now from here we will be
specifically using open AI embeddings
okay openai embeddings actually helps
you to convert text into vectors now why
you specifically require these vectors I
hope you have heard about text embedding
techniques in machine learning right
there we have specifically used bag of
words tfidf and many more things that is
already present in my YouTube channel we
have also used word to work average word
to what are the main aim of all these
techniques to convert text into vectors
because once we probably convert into
vectors we can perform various tasks
like classification algorithms like
similarity search algorithm and many
more so that is the reason we will
specifically be using openi embeddings
which will be responsible in converting
a text into vectors itself now once we
convert every text into vectors we will
also see this as text embeddings once we
get this embeddings what we are
specifically going to do now this will
be quite amazing because understand if
we have a huge PDF document right so
definitely the vector size will keep on
increasing so it is better we store
entirely all this vectors into some kind
of database and for this we are going to
use Centra DB so in short what we are
basically going to do is that we will
take all the specific vectors and save
it in a vector database here currently
we are going to use cassendra DB now
what exactly is cassendra DB so in order
to understand about cassendra DB I have
opened the entire documentation page
over here cassendra aperture Apachi
cassendra is an open source no SQL
database and it can definitely be used
for saving massive amount of data so it
manages massive amount of data fast
without losing sleep right so again
understand this is a nosql database and
for vectors kind of thing we definitely
have to save it in this kind of database
itself many bigger companies are
basically using this cenda DB for this
specific purpose so if you really want
to read more about Apache cendra you can
probably see over here Apache cendra is
an open- Source nosql distributed
database trusted by thousands of
companies for scalability and high
availability this is the most important
point for scalability and high
availability without compromising
performance linear scalability and
proven fall Tolerance on commodity
Hardware or Cloud infrastructure make it
as a making it as a perfect platform for
Mission critical data now how we are
going to probably create this specific
database for that we will be using this
data Stacks platform wherein it will
actually help you to create this Vector
cassendra DB so that you can store
entirely all these vectors into this
specific DB and at any point of time if
a person is trying to query from this
particular DB you will be able to get
that specific response from that right
and the most similar response that
you'll be able to get it now that is the
next step what we are basically going to
do all these vectors we are going to
save it in some kind of vector database
as I said we going to use casser DB or
we can also say astrab and this will be
created in this data STS
platform wherein you can actually
perform Vector search now the next thing
is that after you probably save entirely
all your vectors in in the database
itself then a human whenever a human
tries to query anything that is related
to that particular PDF document it is
going to probably apply similarity
search along with text iddings and is
going to get that specific response so
this this is the entire
architecture that we are specifically
going to perform in this specific
project all the steps will be shown step
by step everything will be explained in
an amazing way along with the code and
along with the explanation now let's go
ahead and start our specific project for
this PDF query with Lang chain and
cassendra DB so guys now let's go ahead
and implement this specific project I
will be going step by step I will also
be showing you how you can create the
cassendra DB specifically in the data
Stacks uh platform itself uh we'll be
seeing step by step all the comment
regarding this code and all is given
over here I will also be providing you
the code in the description of this
particular video so first of all uh what
exactly we are doing we are going to
query PDF with astb and Lang chain uh it
is basically powered and uh understand
it is powered by Vector search so first
of all you need to understand what
exactly is Vector search so there is an
amazing documentation that is given in
the data stack documentation itself so
Vector search enhances machine learning
models by allowing similarity comparison
of the embeddings embeddings basically
means whatever text is basically
converted into the vectors that is
basically embedding right and over there
you can definitely apply multiple
algorithms right machine learning
algorithms on the fly right as a
capability of astrab vector search
supports various large language models
so large language models can be is very
is supported in an amazing way in this
the integration is very much smooth and
easy right since this llm are stateless
they rely on Vector database like Astro
DB to store the embeddings see
understand because uh when we say
stateless that basically means what
suppose if we have embeddings once we
lose it we cannot again query it right
so it is definitely require a database
to probably store all these things and
what you can do after that you can query
any number of time so let us go step by
step and let us see okay so first of all
we need to create a database on astb so
I will probably click this specific link
everything is basically given over here
for this we will be going to
astra.com right so first of all it will
probably ask you to sign in right and
here you can probably sign it with your
GitHub or with your Google account so
here I'm going to go ahead and sign it
with GitHub and probably once I probably
sign in over here you will be able to
see that uh I'll be providing you the
link along with everything in the uh
code itself right so it'll be very much
easy for you so once you go to Astra
data.com the next step is basically to
create a database right so this database
uh what kind of database we are going to
probably create it will be serverless
vector and this is specifically a
cassendra DB okay so here I will
probably give my database name let's say
I want to do PDF query right so this
will basically be my PDF query DB okay
this will basically be my database name
you can give anything as you want and
here I'll be basically be giving Lang
chain _ DB a key space name it should be
unique the provider that you can
specifically use you have multiple like
Amazon web services Microsoft Azure but
here I'm going to probably use Google
Cloud which is the default that is
selected in the next step we will go
ahead and select the country region
which is by default Us East one so as
soon as you probably fill all this
details and as you know that we are
specifically going to use this Vector
database itself because at the end of
the day the algorithms that we probably
going to apply it will be easy with
respect to this kind of database right
so finally we will go ahead and create
the database now once how we create the
database you will be able to see that my
database is basically created over here
right so this is what is my database
that looks like right PDF query diving
now if I probably go to my dashboard
I've already created this kind of
database a lot so let me consider one
database which I have already created
and over here some important information
that you really need to take first of
all I will go and click on connect okay
so when I probably click on connect one
some information you will definitely
require one is generate token right and
the other one is the DB ID so DB ID is
basically present over here right the
token is basically present over here now
I'll talk about where this specific
information will be required okay so
here I will go with respect to my code
now let's start our coding initially we
will be requiring some of the important
libraries like Casio data set langin
open Tik toen so here I will go ahead
and execute it and I will go ahead and
install all the specific libraries so it
will probably take some time right I
have already done that installation so
for me it has happened very much quickly
now the next thing is that as we know
that we are specifically going to use
cass. DB so in Lang chain you have all
these libraries which will actually help
you to connect with cassendra DB and
perform all the necessary tasks like
text T meetings uh creating V vors and
probably storing it in the database
itself so here I'm going to probably
import all these libraries from lin.
Vector stores. cassendra I'm going to
import cassendra along with this I'm
also going to use this Vector store
index wrapper it is going to wrap all
those particular vectors in one specific
package so that it can be used quickly
then I'm also going to import open AI
because open AI is the thing that we
really need to use along with this we
are also going to use open a embeddings
which will be responsible for converting
your text into vectors
along with this if you want some kind of
data set from hugging face you can also
use this and one more important library
that we are going to use is cashio now
Casio actually helps you to uh probably
integrate with the Astra DB right in
Lang chain and it'll also help you to
initialize the DB connection so all
these libraries we are going to use I'm
going to execute this step by step we
going to probably see and this is the
first step installing the libraries and
initializing all the libraries that we
are specifically going to use along with
this what we are going to also import is
one PDF which is called as Pi PDF 2 this
will actually help you to read any PDF
uh read the uh text inside the PDF
itself so this is one amazing library to
probably use okay so here I have
basically used pip install Pi PDF 2 so
let me just go ahead and execute it and
inside this you will be able to see it
shows requirement already satisfied
because I've already installed over here
then from PI PDF you're going to use PDF
reader because this will be the
functionality that will be used in order
to to read the document here is the
document that I have specifically taken
so this is one budget speech PDF so this
is the Indian budget that is probably of
2023 it's a big document with somewhere
around 461 KB file it has around 30
pages so I'm going to specifically read
this PDF and then convert into vectors
store it in the database itself and then
query from the database anything that
you have any information about that
particular PDF now let's go ahead with
the setup okay now with respect to the
setup you require three important
information one is the astrab
application token one is the Astra DB ID
okay so where you can probably get this
two information so go to your vector
database uh Vector database in the data
Stacks so here uh is what you have
specifically logged in okay as I said
inside your DB just go and click on
connect here you need to click on
generate token as soon as you probably
click on generate token then you will be
getting some code which looks like this
this token you will specifically go
getting so this will be probably found
in your token Json file so it'll
probably show you a Json file which will
have this information okay the first
information that you have over here is
the Astra DB application token so here
you can probably see it starts with
Astra CS so what you need to do just
click on the generate token and you'll
be able to see it this is the first
information you just need to copy and
paste it over here the second
information is Astra DB ID right Astra
DB ID is nothing but this specific
information that is your database ID
where do you get it you just need to
copy it from here so this is the
information with respect to your astrab
ID so this two information once you do
it you paste it over here I've already
pasted it and then you can also see that
I've also used some open API key and
this specific API key don't use this
only because Ive made some changes I've
already executed the code also okay so
I'm going to take this three information
this two information is basically used
to connect to your Astra DB right which
has a cassendra DB hosted over there in
the cloud right and the other
information is basically to use the open
AI API features right so all this
information is basically there I'm going
to probably execute this and then we
will go ahead and read our budget speech
PDF so this is the first step according
to this we are reading the specific
document before that we have initialized
everything with respect to this okay so
once we specifically do this I will
probably be reading this
now after reading as I said we are going
to divide all our content into some kind
of chunks right so here is what chunks
we are basically going to do now first
of all I will read all the raw text so
for this I'm going to use from type
extension using concatenate I'm going to
read from each and every pages I will
extract all the text so here you can
probably see for I comma page in
enumerate PDF reader. Pages page.
extract text Will basically take out all
the text from those pages and it will
concatenate in this particular variable
that is rawcore text so once I probably
execute this what will happen is that
you will be able to get all the text
inside this particular variable so you
can probably see over here rawcore text
has all the entire text so this is the
entire text from that specific PDF right
slash in basically means new line so
this step is basically done just imagine
before if we did not had this specific
Library it was very difficult to read a
PDF right and we have actually done this
just with writing four to five lines of
code now the next step is that we will
initialize the connection to your
database I have all my database
information right like uh token ID and
the database ID I'm going to use that
cashio cashio is basically used as a
library over there for initializing of
this particular database so cashier.
init here I'll be giving one parameter
which is called as token which will be
nothing but astb application token and
then your database ID which is nothing
but astb ID right so I've taken this two
information I will execute this you'll
get some kind of warnings so don't worry
about the warnings it is just like it is
showing you some kind of warnings okay
with respect to some drivers issues and
all but this will basically get executed
and now I have uh basically initialized
my DB itself right now we are going to
create the Lang chain embeddings L LM
objects for letter use so for that I'm
going to use I'm going to initialize
open AI with my open AI key and
embeddings also open AI embeddings with
my open a key so I have my llm I have I
have my embeddings okay now is the main
step I need to create my lch Vector
store so over here this is what we are
basically going to create now right and
for that you know we have initialized
cendra right we have we have imported
cendra now what will do is that in this
cassendra we will provide three
important information what is the kind
of embeddings we are going to use what
is the table name inside this particular
database session none keyp space none so
this is the default parameters we have
specifically used QA mini demo is my
table name okay just like a question
answer table name and what kind of
embeddings we are going to specifically
use that basically means whenever we
store any whenever we push any data in
my cassendra DB in my Astra DB itself
what it is going to do it is going to
probably convert all the text using this
embeddings into vectors right and this
is the embeddings that we have
initialized over here so here is the
next step we will go ahead and execute
this so this is my Astra Vector store
but still I have not probably converted
my text into vectors only when when I'm
pushing my data inside my DB that time
this entire embeddings will probably
convert that particular data into
vectors then what we are specifically
going to do is that we will take this
data and we will try to uh we'll take
this entire data we'll convert into
checks uh chunks and we'll also do the
text embedding right text embedding
while inserting right so here you first
of all we are dividing the data or the
entire data entire document into text
Chunk so for this we are using character
text splitter which is basically present
in Lang chain. text splitter we need to
split the text using character text
splitter it should not increase the
token size so here I've given character
text splitter I'm saying use the
separator slash in use chunk size some
chunk size of 800 characters chunk
overlap can be 200 and how much is the
length with respect to that specific
length you can probably provide it over
here right and once I probably do this
you can see text splitter. split text
here you will be able to get all the
text and if I see the top 50 text you
can probably see that I'll be able to
see all the top 50 text over here right
all the data itself this is amazing
right and this is basically from the PDF
right all the data all the data right it
is basically taking the top 50 right and
understand the token size is basically
over here as the chunk size is somewhere
around 800 okay now this is done we have
the text I'm going to just use top 50
and probably store it in the vector
database to see if everything is working
fine now how to add this specific text
now what will happen when I add this
text inside my Cassandra DBC axtra
Vector store what is this this is
basically initialized with respect to
the cendal library right so here you'll
be able to see that I have used
embeddings so now when I'm inserting
inside the cassendra DB what it is going
to do it is going to apply this specific
embeddings also so that is the reason
you'll be able to see that when we write
extraor Vector uncore store. addore text
and I'm taking the top 50 top 50 texts
over there this will also perform
embeddings so that basically means if I
see over here it is going to perform
this task and it is going to insert in
the Astra DB which is having that
cassendra over there right so it is
going to do this both the steps with
respect to this particular code so we
are going to add this text and then we
also going to wrap wrap this entire
inside a wrapper okay so these are the
information this is the index that we'll
be getting with respect to those text so
once I proba executed you'll be seeing
that in the same database it is going to
insert all this headlines okay now
finally let's go ahead and tex it that
basically mean I have my vectors inside
my database now it's time that we just
query and we ask some kind of questions
now I have read this entire PDF guys I
could find out some of the question like
what is the current gbd how much
agriculture Target will be increased and
all so I will take this particular
example and let's say I'm writing first
question is equal to True while true if
first question I'm just say that input
okay it will just ask like what kind of
question you want to type else uh it is
just asking you to uh put more questions
if I write quit it is going to break
otherwise it is going to continue now
see this is the most important as soon
as I give my first question it will go
ahead with v Astra Vector index and
it'll query whatever query text we are
specifically using and the llm models
that we are specifically initialized and
after that we will be getting the answer
along with this we'll also be providing
some information
right like for Doc score or similarity
Source score like some other information
also right so let's go ahead and execute
it and as I said I'm going to use this
question okay how much is the
agriculture Target to be increased and
what focus it will be okay so I'm going
to paste it over here I'm going to press
enter so as soon as I press enter you
can see that it is now taking the
information see this um you can probably
see over here we are quering this
particular DB right and it's going to
give me the top four results okay so
here you can see that agriculture credit
Target will be increased to 20 lakh CR
with the focus on animal husbandry da
and Fisheries right why it is giving
only this much data because I've told
that take the 84 characters or 84 words
84 characters text still there and
probably give the results right if I
increase this it'll give you more result
along with this you can probably see
that it is giving me stop K queries that
is the four query Hyderabad will be
supported as Center of Excellence some
more information but the most suitable
answer that you have specifically got is
this one right and this is what probably
if you go ahead and search in the PDF if
you give the same question you will be
able to see the same answer right along
with this probably if I want to probably
see what is the current GDP if this
information is present over there it'll
also be giving you that specific answer
it'll just do the similarity search
right so here you can current gbd is
estimated to be 7% isn't it amazing now
you can probably take any huge data
because at the end of the day you
specifically using DB right and finally
if you want to quit it I will just go
ahead and write quit and this is
basically quit right so in short we have
performed each and every step now this
is what which is happening whenever a
human is giving an text query text
emings will happen and based on that
similarity search and then you'll be
probably get the output right and this
is the entire steps We have basically
done step by step so guys yet another
amazing video on generative AI where I
will be specifically discussing about
llama 2
uh Lama 2 is an open-source model uh
again it has been created by Facebook or
meta and you can use this specific model
even for commercial purpose uh so this
is quite amazing this is an
open-source llm model altogether I will
try to show you how we can use this
create an end to endend project also in
this specific video so there are many
things that are going to happen and
probably whatever topics that I teach
going forward that is related to
generative AI I will definitely follow
this kind of approach so that you also
get a brief idea about all these kind of
models so what is the agenda of this
particular video the agenda is that we
will get to know about Lama 2 then we
will go ahead and see the research paper
where I will be talking about the key
points uh about the Lama 2 model again
since this is an open source and uh soon
Lama 3 is also going to come up so that
is a reason I'm going to create this
particular video I really want to be in
sync with all the open source llm models
that are coming up right
then we'll go and apply and download the
Llama 2 model so we'll be seeing like
how we can actually use this particular
model in our project also so for that
purpose I will be downloading this model
you have to also apply this in the meta
website itself and there is also one way
how uh we can also use it directly from
hugging face so I will also show you
that and after that we will try to
create an end to end llm project and
this will be a Blog generation llm app
uh all these topics I will be covering
it I know it'll be a little longer video
but every week one kind of this kind of
video is necessary for you all and since
2024 I have the target I really need to
teach you gener in a way that you can
understand it and use it in your
industries also so I will keep a Target
so every video I'll keep a Target like
this target for this particular video
is, L likes not thousand lcks but
thousand likes and comments please make
sure that you write some comments and
I'll keep the target to 100 okay
so this will actually motivate me this
will probably help this particular video
to reach to many people through which
they can actually use this and entirely
this is completely for free which will
also be beneficial for you and I my aim
is to basically democratize the entire
AI education okay so let's go ahead and
let's first of all start with the first
one that is introducing Lama 2 what
exactly is Lama 2 Lama 2 is an again
open source a large language model it
can be it is used and it is uh available
for free for research and commercial
purpose you can actually use this in
your companies in a startup wherever you
want to use it okay now let's go ahead
and read more about it so inside this
model uh it has till now Lama 2 has
released three different model size uh
one is with 7 billion parameters the
other one is 13 billion parameters and
the the best one is somewhere around 70
billion parameters uh pre-training
tokens is taken somewhere around 2
trillion context length is
4096 uh again when I say that if I
probably compare most of the open source
models I think Lama 2 is probably very
good we'll be seeing all those metrics
also so here you can see Lama 2
pre-trained models are trained on two
trillion tokens and have double the
context length than Lama one it's fine
tune models have been trained on over 1
million human annotation okay and now
let's go ahead and see The Benchmark and
this is with respect to the the
benchmarking with all the open source
models so it is not comparing with chat
GPT sorry GPT 3.5 GPT 4.0 or Palm 2 okay
so all the open source models uh here
you can probably see this is the three
version 7 billion 13 billion 65 billion
70 billion right all Lama 2 right llama
1 was 65 billion one uh one model it had
over there so if you see Lama 2 with
respect to all the metrix is very good
MML that is with respect to human level
understanding Q&A all all the
performance metrix is superb natural
language processing gsmk human evalve in
human evalve it is probably having a
less when compared to the other other
open source models so here you can see
in human uh human Val human eval human
eval basically means with respect to
writing code code generation there it
has a lot of problems so here you can
see 12.8 18.3 it is less it is less when
compared to all the other open source
models over here and there are also some
other parameters you can probably see
over here with with respect to different
different tasks you can see the
performance metrics okay so this was
more about the model now let's go ahead
and
probably and this is one very important
statement that they have come up with we
support an open Innovation approach to
AI responsible and open Innovation give
us all a stake in the AI development
process so uh yes Facebook is again
doing a very good work and then soon
they also going to come up with the Lama
3 Model now let's go ahead and see the
research paper so here is the research
paper the entire research paper now see
uh what you should really focus on a
research paper you know in research
paper they'll be talking about how they
have actually trained the model what
kind of data points they have they
actually taken in order to train the
model and all right so over here you can
see that um in this work we developed
and release Lama 2 a collection of
pre-trained and fine-tune Lun language
models ranging in scale from 7 billion
to 70 billion parameters so if you talk
about parameters it is somewhere around
7 billion to 70 billion our fine tune
llms called Lama 2 chart are optimized
for dialog use cases just like a chat
bot and all right uh more information
you can probably see over here what is
the pre-training data see so they have
told that our pre-training data includes
a new mix of data from publicly
available sources which does not include
data from meta products or Services
we've made an effort to remove data from
certain sites known to contain a high
volume of personal information about
private individuals now this is where
ethics comes into picture they really
want to use this AI in a responsible way
right so we trained on two trillion
tokens uh and obviously for all these
things you have to use Nvidia GPU okay I
know guys it is boring to read the
research paper but it is good to have
all this specific knowledge so please
keep your energy up watch this video
till the end then only you'll be able to
understand things right not only here
because later on you'll be having other
models like Mistral I'll probably create
a video on Mistral also in the upcoming
video right so everywhere with an end to
end project everything I will take this
format let me know know whether you're
liking this format or not so training
data we adopt most of the pre-training
settings and model architecture from
Lama one we use the standard Transformer
architecture now you can understand how
important Transformer is right most of
the open source model are based on
Transformer architectures itself right
we trained using adamw Optimizer okay
with so and so parameters we use consign
learning rate schedule with so and so
and here you could probably see with
respect to the performance like how well
it was training BPL process tokens how
many tokens was actually done with
respect to all the different varieties
of llama model now this is basically the
training loss you can probably see
training loss for Lama 2 okay this is
also important training hardware and
carbon footprint it is basically saying
that how much it is using they used
Nvidia a100 I've seen this GPU it's
quite amazing it's very huge okay and it
is very fast also but again with such a
huge amount of data it is also going to
take time right so all these things are
there you can also see time how much
time it has basically taken how how many
hours 70 billion this many number of
hours power consumption this this all
information is there right this is good
to have right all all you should know
like we just taking more energy and all
right and here um with respect to the uh
llama 2 you can probably see with
respect to Common reasoning it is very
good when compared to all the other
models open source model World Knowledge
reading comprehension math mlu math it
is little bit less you can see over here
when compared to the other model I think
it is still 35 itself but remaining all
it has basically come I think this 35 is
also greater than all these things right
MML is very much good it is able to
achieve till 68.9 Google gini has said
that it is reach to 90% okay but again
this is the thing that you really need
to know uh some more information fine
tuning fine tuning also okay this is
very much important guys it has it has
used this uh reinforcement learning okay
where uh and with human feedback so our
R lhf basically means reinforcement
learning with human feedback and this is
what chat GPT is also trained with right
so uh definitely I think as we go ahead
as we go ahead and see Lama 3 and all it
is going to give us very good accuracy I
guess okay so superv fine tuning uh if
you go ahead and just check how
generative AI how llm models are trained
you'll be able to get a video on this I
created a dedicated video where I
explained about supervised fine tuning
how does supervised fine tuning happen
what how does
uh rhlf happens right reinforcement
sorry R lhf human feedback happens all
those things I've actually explained so
here you can see some of the prompts
right a poem to help me remember the
first 10 elements on the periodic table
hydrogen come first as the element one
helium is second for balloons this this
I want you to roast me now see this
statement is also very important right
so uh I want you to roast me I want you
to make it particular brutal swearing at
me so it is saying I'm sorry but I
cannot comply with that request using
language or intentional hurting someone
feelings is never expectable so some
kind of feelings they're trying to bring
inside all these kind of models okay uh
sft annotation is basically there you
can probably read all these things this
is good to have good to learn how this
reinforcement learning with human
feedback was done and all everything is
given over here so uh this was all about
the research paper still there are many
papers to go ahead you can probably go
ahead and check it out uh there is a
concept of reward modeling also reward
is also given right the parameters they
have used two separate parameters over
here and various kind of test is
basically done so this was all the
information about this now the next
thing is that how you can go ahead and
apply or download this specific model
just click on download the model over
here so the third part provide all the
information over here and what all
things you specifically required like
Lama 2 and Lama chart code Lama Lam
guard so go ahead and just put all this
information and click on submit after
submitting probably it'll take 30
minutes and you will start getting this
mail okay
you all start to set building with code
llama you will also be getting the
access from Lama 2 see you'll be getting
this entirely right model weights
available all the models weight will be
given to you in this specific link you
can click and download it also if you
want so that you can use it in your
local or you can deploy it wherever you
want okay so this kind of mail you'll be
getting uh Lama 2 commercial license all
the information with all the info over
here and these all models it is
specifically giving again I told you 70b
70b chat why these two models are there
this is specifically for Q&A kind of
application dialog flow application I
can basically say uh remaining one can
be used for any kind of task uh in a
complex scenarios and all okay so once
you do this the next thing is that you
can also go to hugging face in hugging
face you have this Lama 270b chat FF and
there is the entire information that is
probably given about the entire model
itself you can probably read it from
here with respect to this Lama 2 is a
collection of pre-trained this this
information is basically there you can
also directly use it if you want the
code with respect to Transformer you
just click on using Transformer you'll
be able to get this entire code where
you can directly use this also okay what
we are basically going to do I'm not
going to use 70 billion parameters since
I'm just doing it in my local machine
with the CPU itself okay so what I will
do I will be using a model which is
basically uh it is basically a quantized
model right with respect to this same
llama model it is called as Lama to 7B
chat gml so if you go ahead and see see
this uh you'll be able to see that this
particular model you'll be able to
download it and you'll be able to use it
it is just like a good version but uh
less parameter versions right so when we
say contage that basically means uh this
model has been compressed and probably
provided you in the form of weight so
what you can do any of these models the
recent model what you can do over here
which is of 7.16 GB you will first off
all download it so I've already
downloaded it so I'm just going to
cancel it over here okay because I've
already downloaded it over here okay so
I will do that specific download uh over
here and then you can probably go ahead
and start working on this and start uh
using this and now how you can probably
use it I Will Show You by creating an
endtoend project so for creating an NN
project what are the steps uh again the
project name that I've already told is
basically a b blog generation llm app
here I'm going to specifically use this
open-source llama Lama 2 model again I'm
going to use the hugging face API also
for that uh and let's see how the
specific uh step by step how we'll be
doing this specific project so let's go
ahead and let's start this particular
project okay guys now let's start our
blog generation llm platform uh
application so the model that I had
actually generated over here you can
probably see the model over here in the
bin size and this is the size of the
model is over here I'm going to
specifically use in my local machine for
my local inferencing and all so over
here what I will do I will go quick
quickly go ahead and open my VSS code so
my vs code is ready over here okay now
let's go ahead and do step by step
things that we really need to do first
of all I'm just going to create my
requirement. txt file requirement. txt
file and now I will go ahead and open my
terminal so I will go ahead and open my
command prompt and start my project okay
so quickly I will clear the screen I
will deactivate the default
environment cond deactivate okay and
we'll do it step by step so first step
as usual go ahead and create my
environment cond create minus P VNV
environment I hope I've repeated this
specific step lot many times so here I'm
going to create cond create minus pvnv
with python wal to
3.9 y okay so just to give you an idea
what how exactly it is going to run run
how things are basically going to happen
uh step by step we'll understand so
first of all we are creating the
environment and then we will go ahead
and fill our requirement. txt now in
requirement. txt I'm going to
specifically use some of the libraries
like sentence Transformers C Transformer
fast API if you want to specifically use
fast API I I'll remove this fast API I
think uh I will not require this IPI
kernel so that I can play with Jupiter
notebook if I want I can also remove
this I don't want it langon I will
specifically using and streamlet I'll be
using okay so first of all I will go
ahead and create cond activate Okay cond
activate uh
venv so we have activated the
environment and the next thing is that I
will go ahead and
install all the requirement.
txt okay and in this you don't require
uh okay so okay I've not saved it so
requirement. txt is not saved now in
this you don't require any open AI key
because I'm just going to use hugging
face and from hugging face I'm going to
probably call my model which is
basically present in my local so here is
the model that I am going to
specifically call okay so once this
installation will take place then we
will go ahead and create my app.py and
just give you an idea like uh I'm going
to basically create the entire
application in this specific
file itself so quickly uh let's go ahead
and import our streamlet so till the
installation is basically happening I
will go ahead and install
streamlet Okay as
St and then along with this I will also
be installing Lang chain. prompts
because I'm also going to use prompts
over here just to give you an idea how
things are going to happen it's going to
be very much fun guys because open
source right it it's going to be really
amazing with respect to open source you
don't require anything as such and then
I'm going to basically write prompt
template because we need to use this
from Lang chain then I'll be also using
from Lang
chain Lang chain do llm I'm going to
import C
Transformer okay why this is used I will
just let you know once I probably write
the code for this okay so three three
Transformers also I'm going to basically
use over here so this is going to be
from okay so C Transformers prom
template and St for the streamlet I'm
going to specifically use the first
thing is that I will go ahead and write
function to
get
response from my um llm uh llama model
right Lama 2 model I'm going to
basically use this okay still the
installation is taking place guys it is
going to take time because there are so
many libraries I've been installing okay
so I'll create a function over here
let's create this particular function
later on okay now after this what I'm
actually going to do is that we'll go
ahead and set our streamlet right setor
pageor config see now many people will
say streamlet or flask it does not
matter guys anything you can
specifically use streamlet why I'm
specifically using is that it'll be very
much easy for me to probably create all
the things right the UI that I want so
in a set page config I'm going to
basically use page title generate blogs
page icon I've taken this robot icon
from the streamlet documentation layout
will be Central and uh initial sidebar
will be collapsed okay so I'm not going
to open the sidebar in that specific
page now I will keep my ht.
header so ht. header in here I'm going
to basically generate my blogs right so
generate the blogs and I'll use the same
logo if I want so it looks good okay so
this is the next thing I will probably
this will be my head over here first of
all I will create my input text okay so
input text field right and this will
basically be my input text field and let
me keep it as a um a text area or a text
box whatever things is required so I
will write go ahead and write St
do
st. input textor input okay so this will
basically be my St so let's see
everything is working fine why this is
not coming in the color okay still the
installation may be happening so over
here I'll go ahead and write this I will
say enter the blog topic right so if you
just write the blog topic it will should
be able to give you the entire blog
itself with respect to anything that you
want okay so done the installation is
basically done over here you can
probably see this good I will close this
up now I'll continue my writing the code
so I've created a input box now the
other thing that I really want to create
is that I'll try to create two more
columns or two more Fields below this
box okay one field I will say that how
many words you specifically want for
that blog okay so over here
creating two more
columns for additional two
Fields additional two field okay so here
first of all will be my column 1 let's
say column 1 and column 2 I will just
write it like
this and here I will say St do
columns and uh here I'll be using I'll
be giving right what should probably be
the width like let's say 5 comma 5 if
I'm giving you'll be able to see that
the width of the text box of width of
the column that I specifically have I'll
be able to see it okay I'm I'm just
creating that width for that columns
okay now I'll say with column one
whenever I probably write anything in
the column one or select in anything in
the column one this will basically be my
number of words okay number of words and
for here I will be creating my St do
text input and this text input will
probably retrieve the details of number
of words okay so here I have
specifically number of words great now
the next column that I specifically want
the detail so for whom I am actually
creating this particular blog I want to
probably put that field also so with
column 3 I will probably create
something like this I will say okay fine
um what blog style I will I'll create a
field which is basically called as blog
style okay now inside this blog style
what I am actually going to do sorry not
column 3 column two because I've created
those variable over there okay so the
blog style will be basically be a drop
down so I will say St do select box okay
and I will say what box this is
specifically for so that first message I
will say select
write writing the
blog
for for okay so this I'm basically going
to say that okay for whom I'm going to
write this particular blog okay and with
respect to this I can give all the
options that I really want to give okay
so for giving the options I will also be
using this field so let's say the first
option will be for researchers whether
I'm writing that particular block for
researchers or for data
scientist okay data scientist or I am
basically writing this block
for for common people okay common people
so this three information I really want
over here and this will basically help
me to put some Style filing in my blog
okay that is the reason why I'm
basically giving over here okay and by
default since we need to select it in
the first option so I will keep it as
index as zero okay so here is all my
stylings that I've have specifically
used so if you want to probably make it
in this way so you'll be able to
understand this so this will be my
column one and this is basically be my
column two okay and then finally we will
go ahead and write submit button submit
will be St
dot button and this will basically be my
generate okay so I'm going to basically
generate this entirely uh generate is
just like a button which will basically
Click by taking all this particular
information so from here I'll be getting
my input from here I'll be getting
number of words from here I'll be
getting my blog style okay all this
three
information now this will actually help
me to get the final response here okay
so I will say say if submit okay if
submit I have to call one function right
and what will be that specific function
that function will return me some output
okay and that output will be displayed
over here now that function I really
need to create it over here itself let's
say I will say
get
llama response okay so this is basically
my function and this I will create in my
definition and what all parameters I
specifically require over here right
this three parameters right and uh if I
probably call this function over here
what are the parameters that I'm going
to write over here is all these three
parameters so first parameter is
specifically my text input input
text the second parameter that I'm
actually going to give over here is
number of
words the third parameter that I really
want to give is my block style so like
what block style I really want okay so
all this three information is over here
so this will basically be my input text
okay uh I'll write the same name no
worries number of
words and third parameter is basically
my block style so all these materials
will be given in the description if
you're liking this video please make
sure that you hit subscribe press the
Bell notification icon hit like again
just to motivate me okay if you motivate
me a lot I will create multiple contents
amazing content for you okay now here is
what I will be calling my llama model
right l Lama model Lama 2 model which I
have actually downloaded in my local and
for that only I will be specifically
using this C
Transformers right now if I probably go
ahead and search in Lang chain Lang
chain see whenever you have any problems
related to anything as such
right C Transformer C Transformer go and
search in the documentation everything
will be given to you so C Transformer
what exactly it is it is it is over here
it is given over here or not here let's
see the documentation
perfect so here you can see C
Transformers the C trans Library
provides python binding for ggm models
so gml models the blog gml models
whichever model is basically created you
can directly call it from here let's say
in the next class I want to call mistal
so I can go ahead and write my model
name over here as mist and it'll be able
to call directly from the hugging phas
okay um not only hugging face but at
least in the local uh if you have the
local if you want to call it from the
hugging face then you have to probably
use the hugging face API key but right
now I don't want to use all those things
so I want to make it quite simple so CC
Transformers and here I'm going to
basically write my
model model is equal to and this should
be my model path right which model path
this one model slash this one right so
here you can probably see this specific
name V3 Q8 Z bin okay so I'm going to to
probably copy this entire
path and paste it over here okay so this
will basically be my model and inside
this what kind of model type I want
there is also a parameter which is
basically called as model type and in
model type I'm going to basically say it
is my llama model okay and you can also
provide some config parameter if you
want otherwise it will take the be
default one so I'll say Max newcore
tokens
is equal to
256 and then the next one will basically
be my
temperature
colon 0.01 let me keep the temperature
point less only so I want to see
different different answers okay so this
is done uh this is my llm model that I'm
basically going to call from here and it
is going to load it okay now after my
llm model is created I will go ahead and
write my prompt template because I've
Tak taken three three different
information so template here I will go
ahead and create this will be in three
codes if you want to write it down
because it is a multi-line statement and
I will say write a
blog write a blog for which style right
blog style for whom for this specific
blog style for researchers for freshers
for anyone you can write right or I'll
say job profiles I can for researcher
job profile for fresher job profile for
normal people job profile right so
something like this job profile for a
topic which topic I'm going to basically
say this will be my number of words
sorry not number of words this will be
my
input text so this is how we basically
write
prompts
within how many words the number of
words okay this many number of words I'm
going to basically write this okay so
this actually becomes my prompt template
entirely okay this is my entire prompt
template write a blog for so and so for
block style this this this to make it
look better what I will do I'll just
press tab so that it'll look over here
okay so this is my template that I'm
probably going ahead with I've given the
three information blog style input text
number of words everything is given over
here now finally I need to probably
create the prompt template okay so for
creating the prompt template I'm going
to use prompt is equal to prompt
template and here I'm going to basically
give my input variables so input
uncore variables and inside this I'm
going to basically write first
information that I want what kind of
inputs I specifically want right uh
whether I want um this block style so
for block style I can just write style
second one I can probably
say text third one I can basically
say ncore word so this will basically be
my three information that I'm going to
provide it when I'm giving in my prompt
template okay and finally uh this is my
input variable this next parameter that
I can also go ahead with I can provide
my template itself what template I want
to give so this will be my template over
here now finally we will generate the
response from the Lama model OKAY Lama 2
model which is from gml okay so here
what I'm actually going to do I'm going
to basically write llm and whatever
things we have learned in Lang chain
till now prompt
dot prompt.
format and here I'm going to basically
use email sorry email what are the
information that I really want to give
over here prompt. format so the first
thing is with respect to style the style
will be given as block style so I'm
going to basically write blog undor
style okay the next information that I'm
probably going to give is my input text
input text is equal to not input text
text is equal to input text I have to
give text is equal to input undor text
and the third parameter that I'm going
to give is my ncore words which will
basically be by number of words done so
this is what I'm specifically giving
with respect to my prompt uh and what
llm will do it will try to give you the
response for this and then we will go
ahead and print this response and we
will return this response
also okay
response response okay and what we'll do
we will go ahead and return this
response so step by step everything is
done now I'm going to call this get Lama
response over here here already is done
now let's see if everything runs fine or
not uh hope so at least one error will
at least come let's
see so I will delete this and let's go
ahead and write over here to run the
streamlet app all you have to do is just
just write streamlet Run
app.py Okay so once I probably execute
this you'll be able to see this is what
is my model but still I'm getting a
model streamlet has attribute no head
okay so let's see where I have
specifically done the mistake because I
think it should not be head it should be
header okay I could see the error header
okay fine no worries let's run it
baby let's run this again stream L run
app.py no I think it should
run this looks good uh enter the block
toping number of words researchers
writing the researcher blog data
scientist common people so let's go
ahead and write about
large language model so 300 words so
number of words I will go ahead and
write 300 I want to basically write it
for common people and we will go ahead
and generate it now see as soon as we
click on generate it is going to take
some time the reason it is probably
going to take some time because uh we
are using this particular in my local
CPU but we got an error let's see key
error block style it seems so I will go
to my
code block style block style block style
so one minor mistake that I have
specifically done over here so what I
will do is that I'll give the same key
name so that it does not give us any
issue okay so this will be my input text
and number of words the thing is that
whatever things I give in that prompt
template the input variables should be
of that same name okay so that is a
mistake I had done it's okay no worries
so let's go ahead and and execute it now
everything looks fine have assigned the
same value over there number of words
number of words so here also I'll go
ahead and write number of words block
style input
text and this also should be block style
the name I'm giving same right for both
prom template and this okay so I think
now it should work let's see so go ahead
and write this and now my page is open
opened now I'll go ahead and write large
language models and it will probably
create
my words so this will be 300 I want to
create it for common people let's
generate it as I said that the output
that I'm probably going to get is going
to take some time because I'm running
this in local CPU um let's say if you
deploy this in the cloud uh with respect
to if there are GPU features then you
will get the response very much quickly
so so just let's wait uh till then uh we
get the output hardly but I think it is
5 to 10 seconds Max and since I've told
300 wordss it is again going to take
time so let's see the output once it
comes so guys it hardly tookes 15
seconds to display the result so here
you can see that large language models
have become increasingly popular in
recent year due to the in due to the
ability to process and generate
humanlike languages it looks like a good
blog you can also create any number of
words blog itself Now understand that I
have a good amount of ram my CPU has lot
of cores so I was able to get it in 15
seconds for some of the people it may
take 20 seconds it may take 30 seconds
now you may be asking Kish how can you
specifically reduce this time is very
much simple guys we will probably do the
deployment in AWS or any other Cloud
Server itself which I will be probably
showing you in the upcoming videos and
there you'll be able to see that how
with the help of gpus the inferencing
also becomes very much easy not only
that we'll also see how we can probably
fine-tune all this data set with the OWN
custom data itself guys yet another
amazing llm project for you all now this
llm project will be quite amazing
because from this like this is just like
a base you can probably create any kind
of app on top of it you can create text
summarizer you can create a quiz app or
you can create any other app itself that
is probably something related to text
right so what is the main aim of this
particular project is that from this
project you will get all the guidance
that is probably required to create that
production grade application whenever
you specifically work in the companies
why because we are going to also include
Vector search database and this is where
you'll understand the power of the
vector search
database whenever you work in any NLP
project something that is related to
text you try to convert those text into
embeddings or vectors if you have a huge
vectors you you cannot just store it in
your local machine you probably are
requiring some kind of database and
specifically with respect to vectors or
embeddings V Vector DB is very super
beneficial why because you can probably
apply some of the important algorithms
like similarity search or you can also
uh apply any other algorithms that is
related to text it can be text
classification very much quickly by just
squaring it from the vector database and
getting the right kind of output so all
these things we are basically going to
cover it will probably be a longer video
because every step by step I'll probably
show you I will also write the code in
code in front of you wherever any
documentation is probably required I
will also show you all those things so
yes without wasting any time let's go
ahead and probably see this project my
main aim is basically to teach you in
such a way that you get the right kind
of knowledge and this you apply it in
your company and nowadays many companies
are specifically asking interviews
regarding Vector DB they asking related
to open a llm models and many more so
let me go ahead and share my screen and
as I said we will be doing completely
from Basics right so here is my vs code
I have a document over here budget
speech. PF I am probably going to take
this particular document upload it in my
Vector DB right and then ask any kind of
queries from it convert that into a quiz
app right let's say this is a general
knowledge book I can probably convert
this into a quiz app with four options
and get the right kind of answer from it
right so this is what I'm planning to do
other than this any idea you have you
can probably do it on top of it right so
first first thing first what is the
first thing that we really need to do
over here is that create a environment
right and this is in every project I at
least make you do this because it is
super beneficial because at the end of
the day with respect to every project
you need to probably create a separate
environment so in order to create an
environment I will go ahead and write
cond
create cond create minus p v andv will
be my uh environment name and then here
I'll basically going to use Python 3.10
right so once I execute it it'll ask me
for an option whether I need to install
or not I will just say why and go ahead
with the installation so this is the
first step that we should specifically
do right and uh it is important step
because at the end of the day you should
definitely create a different
environment don't always work in the
same environment whenever you are
actually working in this kind of
projects the second thing that I'm
probably going to do is that create my
requirement. txt
requirement. txt the reason because
whenever I'm using an lmm model or
anything as such I have to probably
install a lot of packages so over here
first of all I will go ahead and cond
activate activate this specific
environment V NV slash okay so this is
done the environment is activated and we
are ready to go right now from my
requirement. txt what are things I'm
basically going to use I'm going to to
probably note down all the requirements
over here the libraries that is
unstructured Tik toen pine cone client P
PDF open aai Lang chain pandas numai
python. EnV and at the end of the day
guys uh I would always suggest you to
please understand about Lang chain Lang
chain is an amazing Library it has lot
of power lot of functionalities which
you can specifically do the community is
huge and many many companies are
specifically using it okay so
requirement. txt has been saved so I
will quickly go ahead and install this
requirement. txt so probably it may take
some time and before that uh since it is
probably installing what I will do I
will also go ahead and create my EnV
file right so in this ENB file what I'm
actually going to do I'm going to put my
open API key so quickly I'll create my
open AP API key save it and start using
it okay so this will basically be my
open API key in the EnV so that I can
basically load it so along with this
python. EnV is also there so let's wait
till the all the libraries has been
installed okay so this is the initial
steps that we should specifically do
right our environment is ready we have
installed all the libraries that is
probably required we have also kept our
open AI key because at the end of the
day I'm specifically going to use Lang
chin you can also do it with hugging
face if you want but I will try it with
open AI because the accuracy is pretty
much better in this okay
now the next step uh what I'm quickly
going to do is that quickly create one
file and here I will just show you test
ipynb and this will basically be my
ipynb file itself and here I'll be
showing you the entire code later on you
can probably convert this into an end
to-end project you can probably create a
streamlet app but here is the main thing
that I'm probably going to show you by
executing step by step and and what all
things are specifically required to
create this app again understand what I
am planning to do right so I will just
show you over here first of all let me
just clean this screen and what is my
entire agenda like what I really want to
create as an llm application over here
so I have a PDF okay I have a PDF so
this is basically my PDF you can also
say this is a data source it can be a GK
book it can be a maths book it can be
anything right I will will first of all
load this document right once I load
this document or read this
document what I am going to do is that
I'm going to convert this into chunks
right because we cannot open AI hugging
face models they have some restriction
with respect to the Token size so I'm
just probably going to create chunks and
this is what we say it as text
chunks right after this I'm going to use
open AI embedding
okay and this embeddings will be
responsible in converting all this text
CHS into
vectors right so this will basically be
my vectors I hope you know what exactly
is vectors a numerical format for
different different text right so this
will specifically be my vectors and this
I'm going to basically do with open
embeddings further this vectors needs to
be stored in some Vector search DB so
here I will put all these vectors in
some kind of vector surge DB now why
this DB is required because at the end
of the day whenever a human being
queries any
inputs
right because of this Vector search DB
here we can apply similarity
search right and probably get any kind
of info that I specifically want so this
is my what my entire architecture of the
specific project looks like right and
here this Vector search DB I'm probably
going to use something called as pine
cone and they have lot of DBS I will
talk about the advantage and
disadvantage there is some amazing DBS
called as data Stacks where they
specifically use cassendra DB Pine clone
is one right we'll see all the
documentation page with respect to this
okay so step by step I'm going to
basically do this and you can actually
do it for any number of pages one more
thing that I'm probably going to install
is IPI kernel since I'm going to work in
my Jupiter notebook okay
so this all steps are basically
happening it is very much good and we
are able to see this okay so let this
installation happen and then I will set
up my kernel okay so these are the
initial steps that we really need to
focus on and uh understand this project
will be the base to create any kind of
chatbot application mcqs quiz apps okay
question answering chat Bots not only
question answering chat Bots text
summarizer anything that you probably
want
right or you can also basically say it
as a chat B that gives you specific
answer with respect to specific domain
right with respect to the data that we
have so all these things are done now
I'm going to probably select the kernel
V EnV python 3.0 right I'm going to save
this perfect now the first step as usual
I will go ahead and import start
importing libraries and now we will do
it completely step by step okay so what
all things we basically require I'm
going toire open a I'm going to import
Lang
chain uh apart from open and Lang chain
what I'm going to also going to do go
ahead with pine con I will talk about
Pine con more when I probably show you
the documentation apart from Pine con
I'm going to basically go to Lang chain
okay and I'm going to basically use
something called as document
loader document loaders will basically
be responsible for for loading any kind
of documents it can be a PDF file and
all so for PDF we specifically use
something called as P PDF I can also use
directly Pi PDF loader but since my PDF
is inside the directory I'm going to use
Pi PDF directory loader okay so this is
the next thing now from the next thing
what we need to do is that as soon as we
load any PDF we will get all the
documents we have to basically do uh
text splitting right because we really
need to convert those into chunks we
cannot take the entire token right there
will be a restricted token size right
like uh recently open has come up with
the open 4. 4. o turbo right so I think
it is GPD sorry GPD 4.0 turbo there 188
128k is the token size right so for that
I'm going to basically use from Lang
chain dot text spitter I'm going to
probably import recursive character text
spitter you can also use any other based
on this right my always suggestion would
be that go ahead and check out the
documentation with respect to all the
libraries that I'm probably uh uploading
right now the next thing is that
whenever I probably convert this into
chunks right the next thing that I need
to probably convert that into vectors
and for that I'll be using some kind of
embedding techniques so over here we are
going to basically use do
embeddings
doop so it is embeddings do openai and
we are going to import open AI embedding
so open AI embeddings is a technique
wherein it will probably convert any
chunk into vectors right so this is the
next step now the next step is basically
also to uh import a library that will be
responsible in creating a vector DB with
respect to Pine call or we also say it
as Vector store so here I'm going to
basically use from Lang
chain
dot
vector
dot I think Lang chain dot it should be
dot I'm writing comma I don't know why
Vector oh spelling is mistaken do Vector
stores okay and here I'm basically going
to
import I think it will be there pine
cone right so I'm basically going to
also use this pine cone pine cone will
be our Vector store uh later on we can
integrate this with our Vector DB that
is present in Pines conone so
the next thing is that I will also
import our llm model because we will be
requiring llm
import open AI right so all these
libraries I'm going to specifically use
it I will quickly go ahead and execute
it let's see if everything works fine
you may get some kind of warning but
it's okay right so this is your
initial load that you are specifically
doing now you know that I have an
environment variables that is with
respect to hugging pH so what I'm
actually going to to do I'll go ahead
and write from EnV
import import load. EnV so this will
specifically load all your environment
variables okay so whatever environment
variables that you have with respect to
open API key or anything that is
required you can basically do this right
now I will also be importing OS over
here right OS we can specifically use
later on okay quickly now the first step
as I said
we need we have a PDF file we need to
read it right so now I will write let's
read the document okay now first step
while reading the document I'll create a
function so that I can reuse it and I'll
write read Doc and here I will give my
directory I can also give my file for
that what library will be used Pi PDF
loader right over here I'm using
directory loader since I have to
probably give my directory name and then
I will basically write file _ loader and
I will initialize my P PDF directory
loader and basically give my directory
path over here okay so directory path
over here right so as soon as I give my
directory path it will go to this
specific directory and it will see
whichever PDF is there it will start
loading it okay and then I will go ahead
and write file uncore loader dot load
right now see why I'm showing you this
step by step because everybody should
understand what steps we are be doing it
later on to convert this into a modular
code it will be very much easy that is
the reason I'm writing it in the form of
functions all these functions will go
into your utils.py file okay and finally
you can see over here I'll get file
loader _ load that basically means it is
going to load all the documents and here
I will basically be getting my documents
right and finally we will return this
documents done right now let's check
check if everything is working fine so
here I'm going to basically write read
uncore Doc and this will basically be
returning my document and here I will
give my document folder so let me just
go ahead and write
documents in string right so this will
basically be my directory
path okay and now if I execute what is
this doc it will probably read all the
docs that are probably there now see
every page by Page content this this is
my first page second page third page
fourth page fifth page like this I have
54 pages in my PDF right 54 Pages now if
you also write length of Doc here also
you'll be able to see it right so length
of Doc I'm going to get 58 so that
basically means we have done this first
step right we have loaded we have read
this particular PDF right now the next
step is basically with respect to
dividing these documents into text
chunks okay so this is what we are
probably going to do in our step two but
till here everything is working
fine so guys now we have finished
reading the document uh now what we are
basically going to do is that we are
going to convert this into chunks right
now for converting this into chunks what
we are specifically going to do let's
see so here I'm going to write the code
here I'm going to basically say divide
the
docs into chunks and again because of
the model restriction of the token size
we really need to do this okay so here
I'm going to basically use defin I'll
create a function which is called as
definition chunk data here first thing I
will basically give my docs then I'm
going to basically mention my chunk size
right so let me go ahead and mention my
chunk size my chunk size I'm going to
mention it as 800 you can also mention
it as 1,000 right don't keep a very huge
value and then I can also say what about
the chunk overlap Okay so so the chunk
overlap like 50 characters can overlap
with from one sentence to the other
sentence right so here the next thing
I'm going to basically create a text
splitter and that is where we going to
basically use this recursive character
text splitter so first first thing first
I going to mention my chunk size which
will basically be my chunk size itself
and along with this
my chunk
overlap which will be nothing but the
chunk overlap that I have basically
mentioned great uh so here I get my text
splitter and now I'm going to basically
up take this text splitter and split all
the documents based on the kind of
splitting that I've actually mentioned
so here basically I'll provide my docs
as my parameter and then I will convert
this into and I'll return this docs
perfect if you want to know more about
this chunk uh recursive chunk splitter
uh sorry recursive character splitter
you can probably check this out
documentation also I'm going to specify
over here uh this documentation is good
to understand what exactly it does and
all right so perfect this is my chunk
data function now what I'm actually
going to do is that quickly use chunk
uncore data and try it on my docs file
right so here I'm going to basically
mention my docs docs is this I've
actually got this docs is equal to
Doc okay and let's see so this will
basically be my documents it is just
going to apply all this right it is
going to convert that entire document
into a chunk size of 800 with the
overlap of 50 okay and probably if I go
and see my documents you'll be able to
see it now see every document has now
been properly mentioned right and the
document that we are specifically
reading is the Indian budget document
right so any question that I proba asked
related to Indian budget I'll be able to
get the answer done this is good if I
probably want to see the length of the
documents also I can also see it okay
just to give it get an idea like 58 is
the length okay great so this is done uh
now the next step what I'm actually
going to do is that I'm going to also
initialize my embedding technique so
embedding technique of open AI right so
we are going to initialize this so here
I'm going to mention embeddings is equal
to open Ai embeddings and here I'm going
to use my API
key OS do environment I can directly use
os. environment and I can mention what
is my API key so here I can say
opencore open AI uncore API
underscore key right so this is what is
my embedding so let let me just
quickly see what exactly is my
embeddings so here is my embeddings that
I'm going to probably use and this is
what is basically used to convert that
text into vectors right so quickly we
have done this uh then I'm going to
probably create my vectors let's say
Let's test any vectors with this
embeddings okay uh and there are various
other embedding techniques like one h
word to uh average word to and all but
uh in open AI embeddings this provides
you a much more advanced technique okay
and over here also it will provide you
some kind of vectors like there will be
some Vector size also with respect to
this okay like every every sentence will
be provided with with respect to a
vector size so here if I want to
probably check and write embed
underscore query and just test it with
respect to anything like how are you
right and let's see what kind of vectors
we will probably get so this is my
vectors that I'm actually getting see
the entire text and if I want to
probably check the length of these
vectors it will also give you the length
of this vectors okay so it is some
something around 15 36 and this length
will be super important because at the
end of the day where I probably create
my Vector database I have to specify
this length okay for my problem
statement now great now let's create our
Vector search DB and pine code okay and
now this step is very much important uh
because after this particular step we
will be able to see what kind of vector
database we probably get okay Vector
search DB in Pine con so let's go ahead
and let's quickly create this Vector DB
okay so guys here is the pine cone
documentation you can probably check it
out uh get started using pine con
explore our examples this this is there
what is the main important information
about this Pine C is that it definitely
helps you in semantic search in chat
Bots also it helps you right where it
probably helps you to store the entire
Vector right and it provides you
generative QA with open integration Lang
CH leral
argumentation uh rag also we basically
say open integration and it has multiple
uses okay so if I probably show you one
of the document or guide right so if I
probably go ahead and click on the guide
right and this is where we really need
to create the vector database I'll show
you the steps of creating it right so
Pine con makes it easy to provide
long-term memory for high performance AI
application it is managed Cloud native
Vector database with a simple API no
infrastructure has less pine cone serves
fresh filtered query results with low
hency at a scale of billions of vectors
so if you have a huge data set you want
to probably work with the vectors you
can probably store it over here in the
form of vector database um what is the
importance Vector embedding provides
long-term memory for AI Vector database
stores and queries embedding quickly at
a scale you know so anytime it is
probably saved if you're quering it you
will be able to get the response very
much quickly now first thing first how
you have to probably create this okay so
if you once you log in once you log in
over here or sign up you'll be able to
see this okay so and here I've already
created one index okay but this index
will not work because see uh in the free
tire right it allows you to just create
one index so I will just delete this and
show you how to probably create it
completely from scratch so this is the
name so I'm I'm going to delete this
index because at the end of the day
whatever vectors you are probably
storing it will start indexing it okay
so this is terminated now we will go
ahead and create a new index so for
creating a new index uh what I have to
probably do is give a name so let's say
I'm giving langin Vector now this is
super important configure your index the
dimensional metrix depends on a Model
you select right now based on a Model if
I probably uh see to it right so here
you'll be able to see what is the length
that I was able to get from my embedding
1536 so this is what is the dimension
that I'm also going to give it over here
and since I have basically doing cosine
similarity kind of Stu or you can also
do Dot product ukan but I'll stay to
cosine similarity because at the end of
the day the similarity search that is
probably going to happen is with the
help of cosine similarity and then
finally we go ahead and create the index
this is the main thing that you probably
need to do this is basically getting
terminated and this was the data that I
had actually inserted but again we will
do it okay so if I go to back to uh um
back to probably a index let's see why
it is not created or still it is showing
terminating it should not not show
terminating but at the end of the day
because one I have already deleted it or
I can just change the name if I want so
but it is created over here okay Lang
chin vector and it is a free Tire in the
case of free tire they will provide you
this thing right now from this there are
some important information that you
really need to retrieve one is the
environment one is the database name
okay so what sorry index name so I'll go
back to my code here you'll be able to
see Vector search DB and pine code let's
let's initialize it I I've imported P
cone I will say do in it okay so do in
it basically does the initialization
here two information are required API
key okay API key with some information
comma the next thing that I probably
require is environment okay so
environment something is required so
let's retrieve this two information
along with this what I can also do I
have to also provide my index uncore
name so here I will specifically say my
IND Indore name index name I've already
copied it from there so it is nothing
but langin Vector let's go and see where
is the API and environment so here I'm
going to go back if I go and see there's
an option of API keys so this is
basically my API key I will copy it and
I will paste it over here okay so Ive
pasted my API key over here now the
environment thing where will I get my
environment so if I go to indexes and if
I click this this is the environment
that I'll be able to get it right so
this two information is specifically
required I will paste it over here right
so this two information is done by
executing it my Vector search DB will
get initialized over there but at the
end of the day I need to put all these
embeddings specifically all these
embeddings uh in my Vector DB right so
over there I will again use pine cone
pine cone which I have actually
initialized and I'll say from
documents and here I will give all my
Docs so from documents I'm going to
first of all give my doc parameter over
here the dock which where which I need
to probably store it in my Vector DB and
then I will go ahead and write
embeddings embeddings what kind of
embeddings that I'm specifically giving
is the same embeddings that we probably
created and then I have my index name is
equal to whatever index name I have
basically initialized so as soon as I
probably execute this you will be able
to see that I will be able to get one
index over here okay so let me just go
ahead and execute it it'll probably take
some amount of time because I have a
huge data over there but you'll be able
to see the changes once I probably go
over here okay so if I go ahead and
click it and if I refresh
it let's see okay whether we'll be able
to see everything or not whether the
data part and all we will be able to see
so here you can probably see query by
vector and all all the data is there if
I want to probably see the vector count
it is 58 because the document size that
you could probably see is 58 right and
these are all the information you can
see over here all the data has been
basically stored and based on the
metadata you can probably see it it has
already done the indexing now any query
that you probably hit it over here in
the form of vectors you'll be able to
get those specific response okay now to
do the query part what I will do I will
apply a cosine similarity so I will say
cosine
similarity retrieve results okay so I
will try to retrieve the results over
here so here let me just go ahead and
write definition retrieve uncope
query and here I will say query K is
equal to 1 let's say k is equal to 2 I I
will probably see the top two query now
the second thing is that if I want to
probably query I will get the matching
results whatever matching results I'll
use the same index dot whatever index is
over here dot similarity
let's see index
dot
similarity unor search right the
similarity _ search what I can do is
that let's see what function I've
actually made for similarity _ search
because I need to probably get those
documents also right so basically uh I
need to also create one more function
over here right and that function will
basically be my similarity underscore
search that basically means what is my
result that I'm probably going to get
right inside this so index. similarity
unders search is a function that is
probably present inside this index
itself right so similarity unders search
and here I will probably give my query
comma K is equal to some K value okay so
what is the k k is equal to 2 whatever
results I'm specifically getting and
here I'm going to return my math
matching results okay matching results
so once I execute it so this is
basically my retrieve query uh example
so any query that I specifically give
with respect to that particular PDF I'll
be able to get the answer now this is
fine this is the function to get the
data from the database itself right so
cosine similarity retrieve results from
Vector DB I'll write it over here so
that you will be able to understand okay
so done this is the function that is
basic Bally required now two important
libraries that I'm going to probably use
one is from langen Lang chin. change.
question answering I'm using load
question answering chain and along with
this I'm also going to use open AI open
AI will specifically be used to create
my model and here my llm model will be
created with the help of this so here I
have written open a model name will be
tax uh text Dy uh 003 and I've taken the
temperature value as uh this one and
then I'm also going to create my chain
where I specific ially use this load QA
chain and load Q chain actually helps
you to create a question answer
application and then here I will go
ahead and write chain type is equal to
stuff okay so my chain is ready my llm
is ready everything is ready now all I
need to do is that retrieve my queries
right for retrieving the queries I will
specifically be using this retrieve
query function also so let's go ahead
and write my definition I will go search
answers from
uh Vector database Vector DB okay and
here I will basically
write definition retrieve answers and
whatever query I specifically give over
here based on that I will should be able
to get it right so if I probably see doc
search then I will write doc search is
equal to I'll call that same function
retrieve query with my query that I'm
actually going to give and then I will
also print my doc search okay whatever
print I'm basically getting now whenever
I get that specific doc search I should
also run this chain chain that I've
actually created right to load QA chain
so here I'm going to basically say
chain. run and inside this what will
basically be my input documents so I
will say
input input documents is equal to I will
give my doc search right the document
that I'm probably going to search and
then the next will be my question which
will be in the form of query right the
query that I'm actually getting so once
I do this my chain will basically be
running and it will provide you some
kind of response that it probably
gets gets from the vector DB okay if it
matches right and then we are going to
return this specific
response done now see the magic okay
once I probably call this function what
will happen so here I will write our
query okay so the query will be I I saw
something right I I basically so this
will basically be my retrieve answer
okay now see this I read the PDF I could
find one question over there how much
the agriculture Target will be increased
by how many cores right how much the
agriculture Target will be increased by
how many cores I have just written this
kind of statement now this retrieve
query as soon as we call it will
basically sorry retrieve answer as soon
as we call okay so here I'll just make
make this function change also the
spelling should be right right
retrieve and here also I'm going to
probably make this to retrieve answers
okay now as soon as I give my query over
here it'll go to retrieve query it'll
see from the index right it'll probably
do the similarity search it'll give you
the two results itself so let me just go
ahead and see the answer over here now
retrieve answer is not defined why okay
I have to execute this sorry now it
should be able to get the answer see so
agriculture credit Target will be
increased to 20 lakh CR with an
investment of so and so information I
I've just put right
uh I can also write any other question
how is the agriculture
doing
right so I may get some kind of question
answer if it is not able to get
something then it will say I don't know
okay the government is promoting
corporate based this this this this I'm
getting that information from the entire
PDF itself right so this is how
beautifully you can probably get this
and now it is probably asking being
acting as a question answer application
right now see this is what is the base
you have a vector DB you're asking any
question and you're getting some kind of
response now on top of that you can also
do a lot of prompt templating you can
probably convert this into a quiz app
you can convert it into a question
answer uh chatbot you can convert this
into a text summarizer you can do what
whatever things you want right and this
is what is the specific power over here
right and this is really really good and
that is what I'm probably going to show
you in the next video on top of it like
how can I probably do a custom prompt
templating on my llm application this is
what I'm probably going to show you in
the next video but here i' shown you
about what is Vector database and why it
is very much important what exactly how
the vectors are basically stored and
here you can probably see see this is
how your vector is stored if I probably
search for any Vector over here I'll be
able to get those kind of response over
here right based on that uh search
itself so start using this many
companies are basically using this at
the end of the day just for your
practice sake it is completely for free
right but if you have if you want more
than one indexes two indexes then at
that point of time you can probably take
a paid tool paid version that
specifically requires in a company
itself so I hope you are able to
understand this Amazing
Project hello all my name is rush nyak
and welcome to my YouTube channel so
guys just a few days to end this
specific year this month was amazing
because I was able to upload many many
videos related to generative AI many
people had actually requested it uh the
reason is very simple because all the
students who have made successful career
transition into the data science
Industry they're working in different
different llm projects so I hope you're
liking all those videos that I'm
specifically uploading um
again as requested if you like this
particular videos and all please do make
sure that you subscribe the channel
press the Bell notification icon hit
like this will motivate me to upload
more videos as we go ahead so it is a
sincere request please do that and share
with many people as uh many people as
possible by you the reason is that all
these videos is completely for free uh
my main aim is basically to teach you in
such a way that where you understand
each and everything in depth Let It Be
theoretical intuition practical
intuition and many more right so what
are we discussing in this specific video
so I hope everybody has heard about um
gini right gini API that was probably
gini model that was launched from Google
obviously the demo that they had
actually shown on the website it was not
true demo they had made made up that
particular demo but now the gini pro
model is available for you and you can
also use it for your own demo purpose uh
we'll understand we'll see a complete
demo like how these models are these
large language models are and how it is
probably performing we'll be seeing
various codes I'll be showing you that
how you can probably create an API for
this and the best thing is that with
respect to this they have come up with
this two different plan you know one is
free for
everyone the thing the model the gini
pro model which is free for everyone it
has a rate limit of 60 queries per
minute that basically means within a
minute you can actually just hit 60
queries price is free Price output is
also free input output is free and you
can start using this uh to just get to
know like how powerful the gini pro is
and I probably used it it looks pretty
much good you know um at least uh not
like that fancy thing what it showed in
the demo not like that but yes we can
compare with chat GPT or we can compare
with open AI apis which perform various
tasks like test summarization uh text
classification or let's say other tasks
like Q&A and many more right so the next
uh plan that is probably go uh that is
going to come which can be specifically
used in industries that is pay as you go
and that basically starts for more than
60 queries per minute okay so here is is
the entire information I will be
providing the link with respect to the
description in the description of this
particular video now let's go ahead and
check the documentation and one by one I
will show you how you can probably
create the API the API Keys how you can
probably load it and start using it okay
so first of all just go to the python
section over here and I'm just going to
click on this Google collapse so as soon
as I probably clicked on this Google
collap you can probably see over here
I've got this entirely okay so we will
go ahead step by step we'll understand
each and every line of code we'll see
multiple examples and then let's see how
good the Gemini API is okay so as
suggested as I told you already this is
like Gemini has come up in three
different version and gini Pro is right
now available for you okay where you can
probably try and uh just by seeing this
things right I I definitely I've already
tried it out I feel that yes it is good
enough right um if I compare with any
openai apis yes it is doing a fabulous
task okay I know the demo was bad but
here the things that I'm going to
execute is very much good so to get this
particular notebook file all you have to
do is that click on python over here and
just click on this okay so this is the
entire information
how you can probably create the API key
and all I will be showing you step by
step okay so let's start this video
before that please do hit like as you
know that I uh I I always thought that
within this year right I may reach 10
lakh subscribers but I could not but
it's okay for the next upcoming 3 to
four months I would definitely like to
reach 10 lakh subscribers okay 10 lakh
subscribers 10 lakh is a very good
number right and just imagine how much
beneficial it is for so many people out
there so so let's go ahead and start
this okay so we will go step by step I
know please try to understand this
things because I will be explaining you
the code what exactly gini API is all
about what this gini model why it is so
good because this is a multi model right
multimodel that basically means it is
trained on both text and images so I'll
show you if I probably give a image and
it will be able to read that image and
it'll be able to give you the
information about that image that
powerful the specific model is okay so
uh we'll set up our development
environment and get the API access to
gini so this is the entire agenda we
will generate text response from text
inputs we will generate text responsive
for multimodel inputs and then we'll use
gmin for multi- turn
conversation and we'll also see how
different embeddings can be applied for
large language model okay so first of
all this generative AI entire there is a
library which is called as Google
generative AI with the help of API you
can use various features that is
available in this gini model right gini
pro model so first of all I will go
ahead and install this entire library
that is Google generative AI okay with
the help of the specific code it may
take some time again it depends on your
internet speed how good it is uh and
then after we probably go ahead and
install this so import the specific
library now here are some of the
important things that we are going to do
okay so first of all you'll be able to
see we are importing path lib text WP
Google generative AI as geni so this is
the allias that we are going to
specifically use and this is the library
that has almost all the features over
there from google. collab you import
user data inside user data you can store
your API key okay I will show you how to
how you can probably do it along with
this I'm probably importing display and
markdown to display the information and
there is another method which is called
as definition to underscore markdown
that basically means whenever I get any
kind of response I'm going to replace
this dot by star because I think this
generative a is gini pro gives some kind
of response where it will be having this
kind of output okay and then we are
going to convert that entire data with
respect to markdown okay so all these
things we are specifically importing now
let's go to our next step setting up
your API key so for do doing that just
click on this particular link okay so it
will go to this makers suit google.com
app API key you can also create Palm
apis from here and all right so after
going over here what you can do you can
actually go ahead I've already created
one particular API key over here which
you can actually see if you want to
create a new API key just go ahead and
click on this as soon as you click on
this you will be getting the API key
just copy from there and here what I
have done I have written the API key
over here okay so don't worry that uh
this API key is not right uh I've
already executed or I've already stored
that particular API key itself right so
probably when I share this particular
notebook with you you'll not be able to
see this API key over there until then I
may have also deleted it from here okay
so the reason don't use this do it with
your own because it is completely for
free right 60 queries you can actually
hit
it now let's go ahead and do one thing
first of all I'm creating an environment
variable called as Google API key okay
so this will basically be my API key
okay and I will remove this I will not
require this and then what I'm doing
over here I'm I'm saying gen. configure
API key and I'm using the environment
variable and I'm setting that API key to
this okay so once I do this done that
basically mean my API is configured this
is the simple steps that you
specifically need to do now what all
models you specifically get from Gemini
API so over here there are two models
one is Gemini Pro this is optimized for
text only prompts so text summarization
Q&A chat anything that you specific Al
want to do you have to use this specific
model that is Gemini Pro and then you
have one more model which is called as
gini provision this is optimized for
text and image prompts okay so for text
and image prompts specifically you can
use gini pro version if you want to
check how many different models are
there just write for M gen. list uncore
model list underscore models will give
you all the models that it is basically
having and it is saying that if
generated content in M supported
generation methods then it will show you
all the both the model name so here you
can probably see that as soon as you
execute this you'll be getting that you
have two models one is gini pro and then
the other one is Gemini Pro Vision now
let's go ahead and let's try something
okay so first of all I'm going to use
the gemin pro model this is specifically
for text related task okay so here I'm
going to use generative AI gen AI
dot there is a method which is called as
generative model and there I'll be
giving my model name so once I execute
this this basically becomes my model so
if I probably go ahead and execute over
here so here you'll be able to see that
I am getting a model trust me guys this
is good enough because if you don't have
open API key also you can use this and
when you use this you'll be able to
understand more about the llm models
okay so now let's go ahead and use one
method which is called as generate
content this generate content method can
handle a variety of use cases including
multi multi-t chat multimodel input
depending on what the under underlying
model supports so here I've used gin Pro
so in this particular case I am going to
specifically use it for text related
task okay so now here we use model dot
generate content and here I'm giving the
message what is the meaning of life okay
so this is the default message once I
execute this you see the response time
the response time with respect to this
particular time it will go ahead and
capture so uh and also remember guys uh
when I was executing some some some time
before you know this was really really
fast right now it is a little bit slow
is it a problem internet connection I
don't know okay so but here you can see
user time it tooks 120 millisecond
system time was 10.5 millisecond total
time was 131 seconds which is very good
like open AI API speed I think it'll
take more than this okay that I
specifically know now in order to see
the response I will use this 2core
markdown and we will write response.
text as soon as I write this you will
now be able to see the output of this
right what is the meaning of life so
here you can see that the meaning of
life is a philosophical question that
has been posed by human for centuries so
and so blah blah blah blah all the
information is very much easily given
and it looks good you did not have to do
any other prompt template techniques to
probably put it in this dotted point it
has considered in a better way yes you
can again use prom template also for
this purpose okay so if the API and now
this is the most important thing which I
like about gini Pro okay if the API
failed to return a result use generate
content response. prompt feedback now
you may be thinking why the API May Fail
it may be because of some of the other
reason to see it was blocked due to
safety concerns okay because of safety
concerns also it may not give you some
response now what may be that safety
concern okay so first of all we will go
and see response. prompt feedback when I
probably execute this I also have these
all features that are probably coming up
this information in the response safety
rating category harm category sexually
explicit probability neg eligible so you
can see it is categorizing based on this
four important categories whether it is
a hate speech whether it is a harassment
whether it is a dangerous content right
and here you can probably see that it is
also giving that particular feedback if
any of the feedback is positive I think
you may not get a response so let's go
ahead and execute this particular code
and let's see whether this works true or
not okay I definitely want to check it
out so I will go ahead and execute and I
will say um I will say Okay I I did not
I do not mean anything to write anything
bad over here but uh I would just like
to see how to insult someone let's
see okay I'm just trying I'm not I I'm I
don't mean to but let's see so here
you'll be able to see that whether I'll
be able to get a response or not and
again over here now now it has becomes
fast right so now let's go ahead and do
this see the response part quicker ex
only works for a single C but none were
returned now I will go ahead and check
this prompt feedback now this is where
block reason safety see over here harm
category harassment medium so this is
what is so good in this ethics is
definitely there right so it is not
giving you any kind of resp resp right
so I hope you have understood the
importance of this okay now similarly G
gini can also generate multiple possible
responses for a single prompt okay it
can also generate right so for that you
just need to use this responses.
candidates now what I will do I will not
execute this but instead we will go
ahead and execute this what is the
meaning of life okay okay so let's
execute this it's
okay um or I I'll just go ahead and ask
a different question can you let me
know about
the future
of future
of generative AI okay so I'm asking this
specific question now let's see I'm not
executing this now it should definitely
give me some kind of
response and this also depends on the
kind of like amount of tokens that is
probably coming from the llm model so
here it has taken 122 milliseconds now
let's see the prompt feedback I think
this is absolutely fine okay and here I
will also go ahead and see my text it'll
give so here you can see the future of
generative AI holds immense potential
and Promises to revolutionize various
style Gan gpt3 this this is there now if
I go ahead and right response.
candidates okay now here you can
probably see that I'm getting the entire
info this is so nice see so this is my
first text right role model find this
this this all the information is there
with respect to all the information that
you will be able to see that right all
whatever thing we executed step by step
we getting everything okay so this is
very very good okay now by default the
model returns a response after
completing the entire generation process
you can also stream the response as it
is being generated and the model will
return chunks of the response as soon as
they are generated which is absolutely
amazing again right so what we can also
do is that you can stream the response
okay no need to wait for the entire
response so let's see okay so here I
will use the same question let me see so
I will so can you let me know the future
of generative now I think for this it
will not take much time when compared to
the previous one one that we had done
right so here I will go ahead and write
all you have to do is that just write
over here let me just
show okay you just need to add a
parameter which is called as stream is
equal to True by that you'll be able to
get uh the response as it is being
generated so let me just go ahead and
execute this okay now I'm not going to
directly print response. text but I'm
saying that for every Chunk in response
print chunk. test text okay and then it
will show
80 like dotted lines okay so we can also
display this in this way so here you can
probably see how fast it was able to
chunk by chunk obviously when chunk by
chunk is getting displayed it will be
very very good right so here you can
probably see all the information ethical
this needed for skill Force long-term
impact on society and all now one more
thing is that when streaming some
response attributes are not available
until you have iterated through all the
response CH this is demonstrated below
so here if I say what is the meaning of
life with streaming is equal to true now
you'll be able to see
that let's see let's see okay so once
this gets executed now I have this
response. prompt feedback in prompt
feedback you'll be understanding whether
it has some problems or not with respect
to that thing now if I directly go ahead
and write response.
text okay
it will automatically tell me please let
the response complete iteration before
accessing the final cumulated attribute
okay so this is a very good problem
statement and now based on your
requirements what I feel when compared
to open AI still Gemini uh API that we
have right it may have more
functionalities as we go ahead but till
now it really looks promising it looks
really good okay now we will try to
generate and text from image and text
text inputs okay so this is also good
now let's download this image so by
using a curl operation I am probably
downloading the image if you see the
image the image looks something like
this okay or I may also use some more
image right I will write cat playing
image okay so cat playing image so here
you will be able to see some images
let's see let's see let's see let's see
this looks like a complicated image I
guess it should find some problem okay
uh downloads okay downloads downloads
here I will
say upload that specific image
okay I will save it let's rename this
image I will say cat. jpj now if I
execute this over here I will write cat.
jpj
okay now this is the image it looks
something like this now what I'm going
to do I'm going to give this image to my
Gemini Pro Vision model and then we will
see what it can understand from this
image like if it is if I say that the
Kay is playing with some cotton fur or
Hol right this cotton holes now let's
see what answer gini Pro Vision gives
right so first of all we will go ahead
and load gini provision okay and then we
will go ahead and generate model.
generate content image and then we'll
say to markdown response. text okay so
let's go and see the
answer so it is going to take that image
here directly we are giving the image
now it is going to understand the
specific image it is going to read and
it's is going to understand it is going
to give me a response in text okay now
let's
see so this looks amazing till here but
let's see the response I really want to
see the response of this and it is
taking some amount of time I think when
we go with respect to the paid API it
will be little bit less but again it
depends on the image size how we are
specifically calling it and all right
let's see I think as we go ahead the
correct answer is play right so here you
can probably see if I go ahead and see
this image right it shows play now it
was not that well but let's see the
previous one okay so let's see the
previous one over here okay I think with
just play it is showing I think I'm not
satisfied with that specific answer but
we can also try with the previous one so
let's say this is the image and then we
will go ahead and execute this let's see
what kind of response it gives us so
here you have some tiffen box you have
broccolis you have some food item right
so let's see till then I will download
some more images Okay
um
let's see let's take this image
also images. jpj I will go ahead and
upload it over
here okay I just want to see the answer
like what all different kind of answers
we specifically get yes uh right now for
this image to text I think we are taking
some time but I don't know like in the
future future it may have a good
response time when compared to right now
but here definitely some amount of time
is basically happening right
or these are meal prepared containers
with chicken BR brown rice broccoli and
Bell papers this also looks good so it
is able to give minute details over here
this is really good okay now I will go
ahead and write play images. jpg
let's
see so this is the image I think this
image is small so it should be able to
give it should be able to check the
image and generate some kind of text
let's
see it was an error post intern please
try a report okay some some kind of
error is basically coming up
okay let's see I I think it was a
timeout issue or I don't know but I
think now we should be able to see the
answer okay it is giving in some Chinese
text okay so this I think works with
some
other other kind of images itself or
where you have a detailed image but
definitely some of the use cases is
failing over here okay so I feel that it
is failing over here okay now let's try
this one okay so there is one more
option I don't know like with respect to
image do we have to give only this kind
of images if I'm giving cat images
playing cat playing
images I don't know what kind of
response that we are getting or do we
have some options to probably change it
we'll have a look okay now the next
thing is that to provide both text and
images in a prompt I'm saying that right
a shot engaging blog post based on this
picture it should include description
this this I think for this uh it should
be able to give right it should be able
to give I think that is the reason it
was not giving that well so now let's
see I will go ahead and write cat. jpg I
hope it was cat.jpg only okay so yes
this was CAD
jpg uh can you include the description
of the
photo of the
of okay uh let's see can you write a
short blog based on this picture okay it
should includ a description of the
photo okay now let's see how what kind
of response we specifically get and here
the second parameter I'm giving it as
image and that is how we are going to
probably get it and uh to provide both
text and image pass a list containing
the strings and the image so this is my
string the first thing that I'm giving
this along with this image so I'm saying
that write a short engaging blog post
based on this picture okay so now let's
see what kind of response we will
specifically get okay and quickly let's
see but I did not find a good output
something like this so here it says like
that only right is designed to handle
multimodel prompts and return a text
output okay perfect so yes uh this is
there now let's convert this into
text the adorable Ginger kitten is
having a blast playing with a colorful
cat toy the kitten is batting at the toy
with a spa this looks good right I'm
really
impressed by seeing the image it is
providing you all the information okay
now let's see one more okay
sparton image I don't know let's see
sparton group
image I will put this image let's see it
looks good I like this image
spans jpg okay so I put this image let's
upload this and let's see whether it'll
be able to provide the description or
not first is observing what all things
are there in the image I think that is
what gini provision actually gives you
okay so here I will say
Spartans do
jpg not directory why spotten it is
spotten spotten Spartan okay Spartan so
this is my image which
looks oops oops oops oops what is the
error now
Spartan okay it is
jpeg okay so uh I'm getting this
specific image of Spartan right now and
let's see how it looks like so this is
the entire image right now let me just
go ahead and give this image over
here okay I'm saying it to generate the
content model. generate content let's
see and I'm saying write a short
engaging blog post based on this picture
it should include a description of the
photo okay so it is what I feel is that
that Vision it was not able to just
recognize everything but the text
information that we getting over here
it's good in this epic scene from the
movie 300 Leon is the king of spot okay
it is able to understand from the movies
also completely right which is
absolutely very very good okay so I hope
you like this this particular video guys
please go ahead and try it out and there
is one more assignment that I really
want to give in this go ahead and try
there is something called as chat
conversation so there are a couple of
very simple by using Gemini Pro you can
actually do it just go ahead and try
this you just need to execute by
appending this in the history all the
information is given over here okay but
yes I feel Gemini Gemini Pro looks
promising and uh yeah it looks good
in some computer vision right the images
that I gave like cat and all it was it
was just saying play so at least it was
able to understand someone is playing
over there okay so guys yet another
amazing end to endend project for you
and in this particular project we are
probably going to create a multilanguage
invoice
extractor and we are going to use gini
Pro API for this gini pro has been quite
amazing you can definitely do a lot many
things I have preped prepared more 10 to
15 different kind of projects that are
related to Real World Industries and
trust me all the specific projects are
performing exceptionally well with
respect to accuracy so over here we are
going to focus on creating a multil
language invoice extractor app we'll be
using gemin Pro we will be writing all
the codes step by step so please make
sure you practice along with me and once
we practice things right one then you
get multiple ideas like what different
kind of projects we can basically do
okay so let's go ahead and first of all
let me show you the agenda what all
things we are basically going to focus
on so here is the entire agenda so in
this agenda what we are going to focus
on first of all I will go ahead and show
you the multil language in wased
extractor app demo okay how the demo
looks like later on we will start the
process of creating the project project
by creating the environment first of all
then we will go ahead with the
requirement. txt what all libraries we
are specifically required and then we
will start writing our code this will be
an endtoend project code step by step
we'll try to build this app again it
will take some time let's say this
project will probably take somewhere
around 25 to 30 minutes and then in
fifth point we'll also discuss about
what more additional improvements you
can specifically do so that you can also
try it from your side and as usual guys
I'm actually keeping Target likes for
every video so let's target uh th000
likes for this specific video because
all these videos will be super
beneficial for you in the
companies so let me first of all
complete the first one that is the demo
okay so here you can probably see this
is my entire app okay and here I have
actually uploaded one of the uh invoice
okay so this is the GST invoice and it
is completely in Hindi okay the best
thing is that if I ask any question
related to this using gini Pro so here I
have asked what is the address in the
invoice so address basically means over
here 1 2 3 uh SBC building DF state so
this is just a common invoice I've taken
from the internet itself so here you can
probably see we are able to get the
entire response so this is quite amazing
not only this I've asked for different
different questions what is the date
let's say if I go ahead and say what is
the
date what is the date in the invoice and
here you can see date basically means
the knock so
that usually this Google gini pro is
able to understand those things okay so
I think we will be getting the response
so let me just go ahead and see it so
it's
running uh so here you can probably see
12 27 21 so all the information in this
specific invoice you are able to extract
just by putting a prompt over here now
the best thing about this particular
project is that it is very difficult to
automate it because I'll tell you uh we
have tried the specific project with the
help of testra OCR and all right just
imagine that Google Germany is able to
perform exceptionally when well when
compared to all those kind of tools okay
so this was the demo now we will go
ahead and probably develop this project
completely end to end and we'll start
from completely from scratch itself so
uh let me go ahead and let me start this
specific
project so guys here is one of the
project that I've started in my vs code
itself so first of all just go to the
terminal so I will show you all the
steps what you should basically do as I
suggested the first step is basically to
create my virtual environment so for
creating the virtual environment I've
already created it so that it does not
take much time because for creating the
virtual environment also it takes some
time so in order to create it just go
ahead and write cond create minus P okay
V andv your environment name okay and
then you can also give python version
and remember to give python version
greater than 3.9 in this case because
Gemini Pro is suitable for python
version greater than 3.9 so here I'm
going to basically use 3.10 and then you
just give- y so that it does not ask you
for any permission while doing the
installation as soon as you probably
press enter so this kind of V EnV
environment will get created in the same
project folder okay so I'm not going to
repeat this thing and probably execute
it because I've already done this okay
so just do it from your site with the
help of this specific command the second
thing is that I will go into theb file
and I'll create an API key which will be
available from the Google okay so Google
API key this is basically for gin Pro
and and if you don't know gini pro gini
pro is again an amazing model that is
provided by Google which actually
provides you in a free way so you can
actually hit 60 queries per minute okay
so here is the API key that I have got
if you want to also create your API key
go to this website okay maker suit.
google.com/ API key and you can just
click on this create API key new project
okay so I have already created it so I
don't want to create it again okay so
these are the first two steps you really
require the API key and you require the
environment now after that you just
activate like you just write cond
activate
venv Okay and just activate this
specific environment okay once you
activate it you will be able to see that
you'll be in that same environment
location now let's go to the next step
in requirement. txt what all libraries
we specifically require so here is
streamlet then you you have Google
generative AI then you have python. EnV
then you have Lang chain you have P PDF
P PDF is basically to load any PDF as
suchar or read any PDF uh then you have
chroma DB chroma DB is specifically for
Vector embeddings so we will try to also
do Vector stores or vector embedding
will try to create it so uh these are
the basic steps that we specifically
require now let's go ahead and start my
coding or creating this specific
application uh I will start writing the
code completely from end so first of all
what I will do I will go ahead and load
my environment variable so I will say
load do from EnV
import
load uncore do EnV so the reason why I'm
doing this is that so that I can upload
my all I I can load all my environment
Keys okay so if you remember we have
also installed python. EnV so python.
EnV is basically for all my environment
variables now I will go ahead and write
load doore EnV so this will what it'll
do it will take it'll load all the
environment
variables all the
environment variables
fromb file okay so this is what it is
specifically going to do we'll do step
by step now you'll be able to understand
and please make sure that you write the
code along with me so that you'll be
able to understand it now the next thing
is that I will go ahead and use
streamlet as streamlet is a better
framework to
quickly you know create an app and
definitely I use chat GPT for taking out
the code and all right so that is the
reason you're able to see that I'm able
to upload daily videos see not the
entire project is created by chat GPT
but how to use stream late how to create
this uh website kind of app you know all
those things I can usually use streamlet
uh use chart GPD so then uh so this is
is my streamlet the next thing is that I
will go ahead and import
OS uh OS will basically be useful by for
picking up the environment variable
assigning the environment variable from
somewhere else okay now this is done uh
the next thing that I want is from P I
also import image okay I don't know
whether I'll be using this but let's see
the next thing I will also go ahead and
import from Google
Dot generative AI as gen AI okay so I'm
also going to import this specific
because gen AI will be my entire
libraries that I'm going to access it
okay so done this is done these are some
of the basic uh things that we are
specifically going to load it okay now
usually when we start our any
application using gin API so what we
need to also do is that we need to
configure uh the API key so here I'm
going to write gen a configure API key
is equal to
os.
getet OS
dot get EnV okay and here I'm going to
get my environment variable that is
nothing but Google API key so here
whatever environment variable is
basically present over here we are going
to take this okay so configure okay so
gen. configure uh the API key with this
okay now
it's time that we will create our
function to
load
gini gini provision since the invoice
instructor is on top of an image so we
have to use this gin provision okay so
function to load or first of all I'll
load the model so I'll say model dot gen
dot generative
generative
model so I'm going to specifically use
gen. generative model and here I'm going
to basically give my model name so it
will be Germany Pro Vision okay so once
I do this that basically means we are
going to use this specific model now I
will go ahead and write definition get
giny
response
input image
prompt
okay so let me go ahead and write model
equal to gen
AI sorry I'll not initialize the model
again so what I will do I will go ahead
and write see the thing is that here I'm
going to give three parameters one is
this specific input input basically
means uh uh whatever input I really want
okay with respect to all the images that
I'm giving and I'll also talk about this
specific thing okay okay the three
important information this input is
basically I'm telling what what I want
the assistant to do okay if I say hey
you need to act as an invoice extractor
you need to act like an expertise who is
very good at uh taking out details from
the invoice right so that basically
becomes my input okay this prompt is
what message I want like what is the
address I actually return this is
basically the image that we are going to
pass okay
so all those information this three
information what we can basically do
I'll write response
dot model
dot
generate content and here we are going
to use this three information first of
all is
input then you have image of zero the
second one and then you have the prompt
okay so this three information basically
when you're generating this content you
can give this three information in this
same way okay input image of zero and
prompt okay so in gini Pro they take
they take all the parameters in the in
the form of a list okay and remember the
first parameter is basically the kind of
prompt that you're giving where your
model needs to behave in that specific
way so I will talk more about it as we
go ahead and finally we are going to
just return the response. text so this
easy it is with the help of Gemini Pro
okay and that is the reason I'm loving
it when I probably compare with open Ai
and the best thing is that I can also
use uh this along with my Lang chain you
can probably use it with different
different things I will show you I've
also created a project where you can
chat with multiple documents okay so
that will also be we'll be using Lang
chain and all so this is the function
that is specifically done now understand
one thing guys um we will do our
streamlit setup okay so streamlet setup
what I will do so here I will go ahead
and copy and paste like this so here I'm
using st. set page config let's say that
I'll go ahead and say over here
multi-
language
invoice
extractor okay multi- language invoice
extractor now in this multi- language
invoice extractor I will probably also
give this information let's say okay now
here I've given one input box this one
input box is my input prompt okay and
this is basically my upload file file
upload so I'm saying that choose an
image the image can be jpg jpg PNG this
is the image of the invoice okay so let
me go ahead and write this message of
the invoice so once I specifically
upload this specific file then we can do
anything that we want okay now the next
thing is that I will create an image
variable I'll keep it blank initially
and let me go ahead and write if
uploaded
file is not none so that basically means
when I've when when I have uploaded some
file then I will go ahead and write
image and again I'll be using image.
open and we will upload uh open this
uploaded file okay now once we upload
this so what we can also basically do is
that we can uh write some kind of image
and all I want to display the image also
as soon as I upload it I probably want
to display it so I can just try use this
st. image functionality and I'll say
caption uploaded image
and we can use this properties Now
understand that this this code right I
have directly searched from uh uh chat
GPT okay and uh I've just written okay
just create me an image where to upload
files and all right uh so very simple it
is not like I am learning from somewhere
I even not seeing the documentation chat
GPT actually provides everything a
Google Power provides everything that is
basically required now this is my
uploaded file now I will also go ahead
and create my submit button so here I
will go ahead and write St do button and
I will talk about it saying that tell me
about the image okay tell me about the
invoice something so this is my message
that I'm actually going to give in my
submit button and finally I have to also
design my input prompt now see this
input that I'm actually going to give
right so this basically becomes my input
prompt I what how I want the germini pro
llm model to behave so here I will go
ahead and create my input prompt just
see this okay this is important and this
will also give you an idea like how
improv prompt works okay how we can
actually work with any kind of improv
prompt I will say you are an
expert
okay in
understanding invoices okay
um
we will
upload we will upload a
image image as invoices okay I'm just
writing some messages
and you will have to
answer any
questions based on
the
uploaded
invoice image so this is just a basic
prompt that I'm specifically using over
here I'm telling this to do something
related to this okay so this is my input
prompt and all I've written it over here
then let me go ahead and write if submit
button is
clicked if submit button is clicked so
this is my default input prompt now what
I will do is that I'll also create my
prompt template itself and probably go
ahead right if submit button okay okay
is
clicked now what will happen if I click
the submit button so first of all I will
go ahead and write if
submit first I need to get my image data
okay now understand over here as soon as
we load the image but still we have to
do some kind of image processing and
convert those images into some bytes
okay so for that again how do we do it
so I will write definition input uncore
image set up so for this I have just
written in chat G saying that and here
will be my uploaded file okay uh
uploaded file uh okay uploaded file okay
see now you may be thinking what I'm
doing in this function in this function
what we are writing is that it will take
that uploaded file it will convert that
into bytes and it will REM it will give
all the image format all the image
information in the bytes now I did not
write this code I just went and searched
in the chat GPT and this is the code
that I specifically got okay and this
code is quite amazing same way nothing I
did not do anything see here if the
uploaded file is not done so we first of
all we are getting all the values then
the image part what all things we
basically require the type the data and
byes data right and then we are
returning the image Parts in these two
format okay the M type and data and if
the file is not uploaded this is that so
this is completely I got it from chat
GPT I'm not bragging anything about
myself and all
um again charit is already trained in
internet data so it's just like writing
an input prompt and I'm saying that okay
I require this two specific information
please give me that information now in
this image data what we will basically
do is that we will get all the image
information so here I will go and write
input image
setup so let me do one thing input image
details
okay so I will call this give a good
name okay and here I will give my
uploaded
file okay uploaded file so uploaded file
whatever uploaded file I'm specifically
getting I'm going to give that specific
thing over here now by this I will be
getting my image data now image data
once I get it okay then I will go ahead
and write my response and go ahead and
call my get Gemini response so here I'm
going to basically write my input input
prompt first p parameter is this second
parameter that I'm going to give is my
image data as usual remember all the
information will be coming in the form
of list okay so image underscore data
and this will basically be my input
input and this input is nothing but
whatever information I'm putting it over
here all this information will go over
here and you have all this information
in this format right now after this I
will get the response and now I will go
ahead and write st. subheader
I'm giving some kind of
subheader and I will write
the response
is st.
WR and I will just display the response
okay whatever response we are
specifically getting okay that response
we going to get over
here so all this information is done and
this is really good now it's time that
we can just run the code so guys now
let's go ahead and run this uh we have
completed almost everything that we
really want to do now is the most
amazing thing whether the project will
run or not okay so if the project runs
it is absolutely good because at the
first time we have written the code and
everything should work fine so here I'm
going to write streamlit run
app.py and let's go and execute
this so it has opened let's see so I've
have downloaded two invoices let's see
what all things will be there first we
will try with the normal invoice okay so
here you can see all the
information who is this
invoice build to okay so I'm going to
put this information over here and I'm
going to click
it tell me about the image tell me about
the invoice on the all the information
will be provided over here this is
good so your client so all the
information is over here your client
this this this this even the number has
been extracted which is quite amazing it
is really a daunting process guys okay
uh let's see I will just take a small
one what is the deposit requested okay
so I will just go ahead and write it
what is the deposit requested this is
good this giving an amazing response so
I will go ahead and click tell me about
the invoice over here and here you go
let's
see what it is going to get so tell me
about the deposit requested it is just
saying your
company uh who is the deposit okay my
prompt is wrong tell me so it is not
able to understand the context obviously
if you don't give the
proper uh tell me how much was the
deposit requested I'll give a good
response Okay so I will go ahead and now
click on it should give uh the proper
answer I think now it is somewhere
169.99 5 it'll pick up that exact info
and provide you all those
information this is good so let's see
169.99 this is good guys this is trust
me this is very very close uh what was
the Consulting fees let me go ahead and
write what was
the Consulting
fees now I think it should get confused
with those two values what was the
amount of the Consulting fees I think it
should be able to give it let's see then
we'll try with some other language
invoice like Hindi and all
okay let's see let's see let's see I
think it should work fine but this is a
good thing guys you can automate this
entire process just imagine it is such a
daunting process for with respect to
invoice just see that whether you get an
invoice all so the amount of the
Consulting fees was
$550 okay it is taking this
information um okay there are some minor
mistake but other than that I think
let's see what is the total what was the
total
discount let's see discount is somewhere
around
17.8 but if you give proper prompt I
think you'll be able to get a good
response response okay 179.1 4 okay so
let's go ahead and try some other
invoice this also looks good and uh let
me go ahead and write this so here I
will go ahead and write what is the HSN
of Lenovo 51251 Lenovo in Hindi it is
written in Lenovo so what is
the HSN
number
of
Lenovo okay I'm writing it in English
5125 5125
I let's see whether it'll be able to
give or
not see this small information also it
will be able to take now over here the
date is denak okay in Hindi we basically
say it as dinak so here you can see
84713 01 0 amazing amazing just amazing
okay so what is the date in the
invoice and you can try anything you can
try different different invoices if you
want I downloaded this invoices from
internet you can also do it okay so yes
here let me see whether you're able to
get it yes perfect so guys this was it
for my side I hope you like this
particular video if you like it please
make sure that you subscribe the channel
and all the information regarding this
will be given in the description of this
particular video this video we are going
to see how we can actually build a
conversational Q&A chat bot with the
help of Gemini Pro API not only that
we'll also try to save all this chat in
the form of a history and will will also
display all the results that we all had
a conversation about that is the reason
we are discussing about conversational
Q&A chatbot so before I go ahead guys we
will keep the light Target of this
specific video to th000 so that I will
definitely get motivated and I'll try to
bring more similar kind of projects for
every one of you out there now before I
go ahead please let me go and go ahead
and show you the demo so this is how the
demo demo will look like so if I ask hi
you can probably see I will be getting
the answer the response how can I assist
you today the chat history is Ive asked
hi bot says hi hello how can I assist
you so let's say if I go ahead and ask
what is generative AI okay all all the
previous information I really need to
record it somewhere right so let's see
after this the chat history right now is
this much right so generative AI also
known as so and so all the information
is coming up and after that your chat
history will also get updated and the
best thing is that I'm streaming all the
specific data okay so how streaming
actually works and all we'll also be
discussing about that so here you can
see in the history I've asked what is
generative Ai and this is specifically
all the information now this is what we
are going to implement step by step I'll
show you each and everything again all
the files regarding this all the code
regarding this will be given in the
description of this particular video so
let me go ahead and let me solve this
specific project so guys I have opened
my VSS code over here and right now uh
if you remember in my previous video
I've discussed about all these things
like vision. py how you can actually
play with images with the help of gini
API gini Pro API then we also discussed
about some kind of simple Q&A chat B now
in this video I am going to show you
this entire code with respect to this
qpy so here is what is my entire code
I'm going to specifically write step by
step I'll try to show you what all
things is basically required as usual
first of all we need to have an
environment file with respect to Google
API key this you can actually get it
from makes. google.com so from there
which will basically provide you all the
features to create the API key for gini
pro the first thing is EnV file once we
create the EnV file then we will go
ahead and start implementing our code if
you have not seen all the videos in My
Gin playist I would suggest go ahead and
have a look so let me quickly write over
there all the code so first of all I
will go ahead and uh load all the
environment variables so for this I will
use
forv um import
loore EnV okay and then we will go ahead
and initialize load. EnV and finally I'm
going to import
streamlet as
STD so I'm going to use streamlit over
here and remember one thing guys there
are some important libraries that you
need to install that is present in the
requirement. txt everything will be
provided in the description of this
particular video the GitHub code right
so I'm going to use streamlet Google
generative a and python. EnV all this
Library needs to be installed before
ahead right so I'm importing stream.
asst then I will go ahead and import OS
because I will be requiring it and then
I will say import Google do generative
AI as gen okay so I'm going to use this
Library only for doing all my task now
initially whenever we load any
environment key first of all we need to
set this in my gen AI so for doing that
I will write gen ai. configure configure
is a method where it will be asking for
the API key that I have and since I've
already loaded that from my environment
so you can see that os. getv I'm using
this Google API key okay now the next
thing over here I will try to create a
function function to load gini pro model
okay so here you can probably see gini
pro gini pro model and get response okay
so I'm doing this and here you have
model.
geni Dot
generative model I'm going to initialize
my generative model itself and in this
case also I'm going to use gini Pro okay
so gini pro and gini pro vision for
conversational Q&A we will specifically
be using this one that is called as
Gemini Pro okay and then we will go
ahead and execute it and write chat
model dot startor chat and here I'm
going to specifically use history
okay so this history will also maintain
all the things that we are probably
going to uh have in our conversation but
I will show you another way where I'll
use the power of streamlit to store all
the history in a form of a session later
on you can also put that inside your DB
or you can also use it from your session
itself right uh so first of all let me
go ahead and Define my definition so
here I will basically write definition
get gini under underscore
response response and inside this
response I will specifically give my
question whatever question we have asked
so this function should basically uh you
know give me the response that I'm
getting from the generative model itself
like from the Gman Pro right so this
question I will send it to my llm model
and then I will specifically get the
response so here I'm going to write
response
chat. sendor
message and here I'm going to basically
write question stream is equal to True
okay so stream is equal to true because
as the llm model is giving you the
output we are going to stream it and we
are going to display it right and then
we will go ahead and return the response
so once this response is basically
coming this response is nothing but it
is the output right when we specifically
get response. text now we are going to
initialize our stream late app for
initializing it what we are going to do
is that I'm going to use this three
Fields one is the Q&A demo J Min L
application page config and header it is
very much common the most important
thing is that if I really want to record
the History part right the history of
the conversation we will initialize
session state so in stream late it
provides you session States for chat
history if it does not exist I'm saying
if chatore history not in session State
then we will go ahead and create a sess
State and we'll right chatore history
over here so right now it is blank as
soon as we have any conversation later
on we will try to record all those we'll
try to put all those conversation inside
this particular session state that is
what we are going to look at then in the
next step we are going to basically say
input is equal to
st. textor
input and here I'm going to basically
use
input
input and here we are basically going to
write key is equal to input okay so
input will be my variable name in short
whatever text box I'm specifically using
along with this I'm going to also use a
submit button St do
button and here I'm going to basically
write
ask the
question okay so what I've actually done
I've initialized my session okay session
state so here that the name of the
session state is chat history okay
now if I click on submit or input right
basically both the fields input should
also be filled okay so if both this
satisfies both this conditions satisfies
then what I will do I will write I will
go ahead and call my get Gemini response
and here I'm going to basically give my
input whatever input I am probably
giving it as soon as it calls this
function it is going going to get that
message and it goes to get that response
okay
now the next thing is that add user
query and response to session chat
history now see as soon as I probably
have created this input this is what is
my input that user has given and this is
what is the output that we have got
right now what I'm actually going to do
here for all this entire history right
we going to save this in our chatore
history session state so for that we
will go ahead and write St do session
State okay st. session State and here we
going to basically use chatore history
okay chatore history and I'm going to do
append with this
specific let's say I'm going to write
you basically you who's sending the
message
and then I'm going to basically use
input
okay so I am storing all this session
inside this particular U variable okay
and finally I will get my response also
so let me write over here St
Dot subheader and here I will write a
statement saying that the response
is the
responses and in short I have to
probably display the response Now
understand one thing we used something
called as stream is equal to true that
basically means this entire response can
without getting the entire content can
also be populated in whatever Pages we
want to probably display right what what
do I mean is that now my process did not
have to wait for the entire content to
come from llm so as llm is sending text
Data whatever response it is basically
sending it is going to display it in the
front end screen okay so that is what we
are basically looking at so now I'm
going to write from Chunk in
response see that is the reason when we
write stream is equal to True okay that
basically means we get the exess of all
the streaming data and then we can write
a for Loop and I'm saying from Chunk in
response and here I write st. write and
we will go ahead and write chunk.
text so we are displaying the text part
by part and along with this I will go
ahead and append this entire
response okay and here instead of
writing you I will write bot okay and
inside this instead of writing input I
will go ahead and write my entire chunk.
text so what I'm actually doing is that
as soon as I get the response it is
coming in the streaming manner we are
displaying it and accordingly we are
also appending in this chatore history
okay now this is perfect this is done
and finally what I will do is that I
will just go ahead and create my history
because I need to display all the
history right so here I will go ahead
and write the chat history is okay so
this is what I am going to basically
Implement
and and here I will say for RO comma I
will create two common variables in St
dot session State and here I'm going to
use my chatore history okay
chatore history and whatever is there it
is either in the ski value pairs U colon
bot colon some kind of answers here I'm
going to basically write st.
write I'll use a f one over here and I
will say
roll
colon and then here I will say text so
in this specific format
okay roll colum
text now let's go ahead and see if
everything works fine or not okay and I
will go ahead and open my terminal I'll
delete this let's see so we are now
displaying perfectly all our details uh
this VNV has got activated I've already
shown you in my previous video how to
activate V EnV environment also and here
we will go ahead and write stream late
run uh QA chat q a chat. py and let's
see if everything works fine or not
so it has got executed so here is my
things I will say Hi how are
you and then we will go ahead and ask
the question let's see whether we'll get
the response the response is I'm a
conversational AI chat B this the chat
history is having all the details okay
and it is giving chunk by chunk you can
see over here right uh let's ask some
other question my name is krishn okay
something
krishn what is your name okay something
like this and I will go ahead and ask
the question let's see whether this is
getting saved or not
okay so here you can see how are you
this my name is Krishna what is your
name I'm a chat bot assistant I do not
have a name bot designed to help users
so and so so all the information that I
probably type it over here along with
the response it is getting recorded in
the chat history now this is what I
really wanted to show it to you and it
was so much easy many people had asked
this specific question in my upcoming
video what I'm going to specifically do
is that I'm going to create a PDF
document with the help of gini API I'll
show you different embedding techniques
how we can convert a word into vectors
and then how we can utilize for a normal
document Q&A kind of thing with the help
of Gemini API right so I hope you like
this particular video this was it for my
side all the information regarding this
will be given in the description of this
particular video thank you take care
have a great day bye-bye